donald trump hasn't been
saying a whole lot in this past week but
he did recently come out and saying
impeachment was a bad idea he's saying
he's not going to get removed under the
25th amendment and i think he's probably
right
because when nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer called mike pence he had them
wait on hold for 25 minutes
and then the aide came back on and said
he's not going to take your call so that
was kind of brutal
i really don't think they're going to
get what they want but they are moving
to impeach and here's where it gets a
little different however
mitch mcconnell is reportedly pleased
that republicans are expressing their
intent to vote to impeach trump well
he's pleased
that democrats are moving forward
there's now reports from some from one
new york times reporter
that up to 20 republican senators are
open to convicting the president
i couldn't believe it myself when i
heard it because i'm like well that
would be the end
of all of these republicans you know
what though it probably already is
most of them have already said no to
trump so i can't imagine
trump voters the actual party the actual
republican party base
are gonna turn out for most of them i
mean look they they'll get some but they
lost in georgia
i don't know what's gonna happen in 2022
but they do have the you know
gerrymandering on their side right now
because many of the
many house level legislatures were won
by republicans or i should say you know
their senates and their general
assemblies etc so they might be able to
gerrymander their way into a victory
but i got i kind of feel like trump
supporters may go an entirely
different direction so we'll see how
that plays out but we got other news too
this is crazy stuff reports coming out
that they're expecting
massive riots or protests at 50 state
capitals
that they're they're saying now 4 000
people will surround congress if they
try to impeach trump
and i'm not sure i believe any of this
stuff it seems extremely exaggerated and
when you follow actual trump forms
none of them are talking about this in
fact they're actually calling it out but
who knows what's going to happen
we've got a statement now from the joint
chiefs that the
form the the retired officers who were
on the ground at the capitol were
committing sedition and their warning
against following maga i guess so
things are getting a whole like just
kind of crazy and i'm hoping everybody
can calm down
but now we have this other story from
project veritas now this one's creepy
pbs's principal council saying even if
biden wins we're going to take their
kids and send them to like re-education
camps
you got a lot of really crazy people in
this country even if it's just someone
trying to talk smack behind the scenes
that's crazy
who like this guy from the veritas video
imagine him talking to someone
and apparently that's supposed to be
endearing like i'm trying to win favor
with this individual i just met
let me tell him i'm in favor of
re-education camps
you got to be kind of crazy to think
someone's going to want to hear that
so we'll talk about a lot of this we've
also got the cia releasing ufo documents
which will probably prove to be a whole
lot of nothing but joining us is
dave smith how's it going man what's
going on brother thanks for having me
yeah who are you
me i don't know i'm dave just so we
we saw him at the grocery store there's
a guy buying chips and we're like hey
what's your name and you're like dave
i was like hey i'm on the shelf you know
what i just met you but i believe in
re-education camps
and i was like that's not like i got to
have you on the show this is interesting
we definitely should have some
contrarian pro authoritarian you know
gestapo type voices on the show
uh well uh so i guess you're actually a
comedian i am a comedian
yes i've been doing i've been doing
stand up for uh 13
years and i'm a libertarian podcast host
host of part of the problem and uh you
know
that's it fan and a fan of you guys i
appreciate it man we're glad to have you
maybe we'll we'll get to laugh today
instead of being freaked out you know
what i mean
no i'll probably just freak you out more
okay cool cool yeah like you know it's
all entertaining
i like horror movies myself so how about
a combination of both
laughing and terrified at the same time
so like we'll laugh
yes i got the tissues ready
we're good to go and luke's chilling oh
yes hi i live in a parking lot and
i sell t-shirts on we are change.org
forward slash
shirts so hi that's that's who you are
yeah that's me a t-shirt vendor who
lives in a parking lot
essentially if you if you if you really
narrow it down
yes this is the caliber people i have on
this show yeah a guy
picked up at a grocery store and the
dude who sleeps in the parking lot
selling t-shirts yeah this is going to
be excellent political commentary yes
luke's actually an independent
journalist thanks luke well you know
how to sell it also there's breaking
news happening right now i just saw this
on my twitter with the vice president
announcing that he will not be invoking
the 25th
amendment i think this is also some
breaking news just happening right now
he just issued another letter
uh mike pence really loves his letters
but he just released it it just came out
and uh a lot of people especially mitch
mcconnell are going to be
and lynn cheney are going to be very
disappointed
liz u.s senator who are going to be very
disappointed with
we will talk about this uh but don't
forget sauropolis is pushing on i'm here
in the corner i'm the only sane one here
tonight you're welcome
ian is sick today unfortunately yeah i
guess he got you know i don't know if he
got sick the other night he went up
early
no come on just kidding not even funny
so uh
yeah we'll talk about much stuff let's
get started with this uh this first
story
and this one is senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell is pleased
at the prospect of trump being impeached
new report says when i think of mitch
mcconnell being pleased
i want to think of like mr burns going
excellent but mcconnell is kind of like
a turtle
excellent you know it reminds me of like
disney
they say from business insider senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell believes
president donald trump has committed
multiple impeachable offenses and is
pleased at the idea of trump being
impeached and removed from office
the new york times reported on tuesday
the democratic controlled house is
expected to vote on impeaching trump
on a charge of inciting an insurrection
on the u.s capitol on wednesday
this would make trump the first
president in american history to be
impeached twice
mcconnell thinks that trump being
impeached and then potentially convicted
and ousted from office by the u.s senate
will make it easier to purge him from
the party
the times said citing people familiar
with his thinking
oh please i always love when they put
those lines in there
familiar with his thinking what does
that mean it's basically new york times
does it all the time yeah it's an excuse
to not have to be a journalist
so you can just basically say oh well
someone familiar with his thinking and
then no one can really hold you to
account because what does that even mean
it means some random person was like oh
i bet i bet he wants to uh you know
purge trump
well you've read you know if you've
watched enough fox news to know what
mitch mcconnell thinks
yeah we'll roll with it yeah everyone's
familiar with all of these criminals
thinking at this point but
they're they're familiar with trump's
thinking yeah we're all very familiar
um but now he can't he can't express
what he's thinking on twitter anymore
i think wouldn't it be funny if like
donald trump because the the last thing
he really has is that the old school
thing where the president can interrupt
broadcast television but like if trump
just did it like every 15 minutes to
like
tell you what he was going to tweet like
he just comes in and he's like we had
the biggest crowd sizes
all right i'll be back i mean what if he
just went happy cinco de mayo here's my
taco bell
no but what if he just did it and it was
just him hanging out
and he just talked for hours and all tv
was just taken over
he's so funny he also has the
presidential texting system
yeah you can go when it'll be like trump
saying you know we had a huge rally it
was the biggest
everyone agrees i did nothing wrong
could you imagine getting his tweets
forcefully because twitter bans him so
he's like
that's kind of been the joke trump trump
supporters are saying he's going to
start spamming
through the presidential alert system
well i'd be here for it that's pretty
entertaining
i'd be i i think it'd be a good time you
know you know life is fairly boring and
routine
you know and this pat these past several
years have been so psychotic
and just everything constantly getting
crazier and crazier i think everybody's
like a little vacation
maybe maybe that's that's the good with
with boring old biden
who fumbles and mumbles and doesn't give
pressers at the very least people
the media i should say won't have
anything to talk about yeah i guess the
ramifications are the political
destruction
that will come following this so oh yeah
no that's bad it's pretty bad if you
know you're like a citizen in syria or
something like that but there i think a
lot of people voted for
for that reason yeah but i think taiwan
are freaking out
yeah and they maybe they should be uh
but i think a lot of people
it's not just trump fatigue it's like
the the media fatigue too like they're
just so
over this whole thing and just want like
people
crave normal no the media is panicking
like well yeah they're actually there
there's a journalist i'm not gonna say
her name but she tweeted
i don't know what i'm going to do like
my whole career was built upon
donald trump and now trump's gone has
nothing to write about well
did you see that that reply guy to trump
who was just like
it's more unsettling not knowing what
trump is thinking it's like oh
he's going to cry now is it unsettling
or do you just realize you have no
meaning in your life
so that might be what's unsettling but i
think the problem
that all of the establishment types are
going to run into because this is a big
moment for them like they've they got
the guy out who they wanted to get out
then they have this great excuse with
the capital riot where they can be like
aha see we were right about everything
and right-wing violence and all of this
stuff
and then they go well maybe we'll
impeach him now and that'll purge him
from
the problem is that the 74 million
people who voted for donald trump
the vast vast vast majority still really
really like donald trump
and the the core of it is that they like
his policies better than the neocon
policies
that what he stood for and i like some
of it
not all of it don't like the job he did
as a president but if somebody gets up
there and gives a jeb bush policy
this is what we need to do we need to
invade every country in the middle east
have wide open borders
bail out banks what you know what i mean
like the bush
policies and then trump says how about
we actually restrict immigration don't
fight these stupid wars
re-look at some of these trade deals
make sure it works for america and we're
not outsourcing jobs
that is enormously more popular amongst
the republican base and they can't purge
that
well here's the best part the
republicans are i guess doing everything
in their power to figure out how to
never win again
yeah because we have this story from cnn
politics liz cheney
number three house republican to vote to
impeach trump
you know look if if they think this is
going to win for them
i i don't know what to tell them because
paul after poll even all the polls that
were wrong consistently show
trump has the overwhelming majority and
i don't mean like 70
i mean 90 to 95 of the republican party
supports the president
now here's where i find something really
interesting not that i trust
the new york times too much but jonathan
martin says
a senate republican aide tells me he
thinks there were about 20
give or take republicans who were open
to a conviction
before our story on mcconnell will that
be enough
to actually get to 67 senators i don't
think so
i don't think these people want to end
their careers right now or get primaried
because they would
you you know any any republican senator
who comes out in favor of impeaching
trump
first of all it's not going to do
anything i mean what pence becomes
president for two days
and then joe biden is the 47th president
and then
it's ridiculous maybe they'll impeach
him after he leaves i guess
sure well the daily mail actually just
started a countdown
with the days left to have donald trump
in office and it's
i think it's at 183 hours right now
and when we look at a lot of these calls
we're seeing john bolton
liz cheney mitch mcconnell not really
the best of the best
taking the front leadership when it
comes to calling for
uh impeachment and again there's they're
specifically trying to get him for quote
incitement
of insurrection donald trump made some
very strong statements against that
today but uh we pretty much see the
establishment
uh trying to purge as mitch mcconnell
was alluding to donald trump from the
republican party i think that was
someone familiar with his thinking
okay no no for real for real business
insider says mcconnell thinks
trump being impeached and then
potentially convicted announced it from
office by the u.s senate quote
will make it easier to purge him from
the party the times
said citing people familiar with his
thinking
they have attributed this quote or this
idea to mcconnell that he never said
these people are crow the media in this
country
is psychotic yeah that is the most
insane trash i've ever heard
but you know what this is what it's been
for the for i mean it's been this way
for a real long time it's only getting
worse
well it's it's so hard sometimes i felt
this way for the last four years where i
just want like if i even if i have
something i really want to criticize
trump on and i'm like i think he did
such a terrible job with this
then all of his critics are so insane
that you end up spending most of your
time being like okay no i'm sorry
right like no he's not a russian agent
okay like that's not
but then there's legitimate issues like
yemen like like the
he said weapons deal with saudi arabia
have to be addressed against donald
trump but guess what we're not talking
about those legitimate issues that
actually could change policies we're
talking about if he was a russian agent
based off no evidence at all yes but you
know what but you're right but and the
truth is right
donald trump should be tried for war
crimes for what he did with the saudi
government to the people of yemen
he should he should be tried and end up
sitting in a jail cell after a trial
uh next to george w bush and barack
obama for the rest of their lives
i mean it's just awful you're talking
about the mass
slaughter starvation of hundreds of
thousands
of women the worst humanitarian crisis
in the world
right now and it's in a community no uh
no no no no no no it's worse it's worse
than less worse it's worse than that
dude
you're talking about you're talking
about babies
and old people uh start puking and
and diarrheaing themselves to death
because they have cholera
because we put a full the saudis you
know no the
saudi u.s coalition yes in other words
the united states of america
and their you know propped up regime in
saudi arabia put a full blockade around
what was already the poorest country in
the middle east right
i mean the united nations called it the
number one humanitarian crisis
in the world i'm sure you could make an
argument with a few other really bad
situations but it is
i mean it is just people should go to
jail
somebody somebody actually commented
right when we started that they believe
trump was the greatest president of our
lives but should be tried for war crimes
both are true
it's interesting that's an interesting
that's an interesting thing it could be
a statement about the past presidents
we've had and the
horrifying things they've done well he's
definitely he's not as
bad as or obama but that's not setting a
big bar
it's a very low bar with a lot of war
criminals with a lot of crimes that
had so many people suffering from it and
another thing to really consider here
there's even
associated press articles and
investigations that looked into how this
saudi u.s coalition was working with
al-qaeda
and sunni rebel groups inside of yemen
to go after the the hutsy
iranian-backed rebels in that country
it's pretty much a proxy war between
iran and saudi arabia
the united states is on the side of
saudi arabia and they're doing some
god-awful things
behind al qaeda and again this is
something that even the associated press
admits
and talks about through their own
investigations yes if you could imagine
right and i know like you
like got like kind of made your bones in
like the post 9 11
you know world but could you imagine
right even with all of the opposition to
the terror wars
which deserved all of it they were
absolutely horrible but that you would
say like
if i could have grabbed you in 2005 and
told you that in 2020 and 2021
that america would be fighting on the
side
of saudi arabia and al qaeda
in in yemen that we would be that barack
obama
and uh john brennan and the cia and
saudi arabia and turkey and israel would
be
arming al qaeda in iraq and arming isis
that now
we've actually transitioned the war on
terror to the war
for terror is it it would have made
americans heads explosive i don't i
don't think so i think that would have
been like sounds about right
i think what would have made their heads
explode if you said and it was coming
off of a donald trump presidency yes
yeah that might be their heads would go
that might have uh guess what that's
still not as bad as what bush and obama
did because
trump didn't start any new wars let's be
honest yeah
it's it's not as bad as what biden will
do yes so i i quite possibly i mean
we we had on china uncensored they
talked about some of the people that
biden's bringing on have praised china
and defended them
in some of their horrific actions in the
south china so they argued specifically
that a china
rise is good for the global economy and
we need to not stand in the way of china
becoming the
world hegemonic power that's literally
officials that are in the state
department under joe biden that are
coming in right now that are going to be
setting policies
and as we were saying the people of
taiwan and i said this right after the
election are the biggest
losers of this presidential so let me
ask you uh guys then
how much of what was going on with saudi
arabia i mean this this was going on
with brendan this is going on the obama
administration yeah yeah
this started under obama so is this i'm
just this
the the war in yemen started the
relationship with saudi arabia goes back
it goes back to henry kissinger
literally going to saudi arabia and
arguing for the larger petro dollar on
the world
right so henry kissinger again hands in
china hands in
right wing you know dictatorships
left-wing dictatorships and also
establishing saudi arabia as the global
hegemonic power in the middle east so
can i just say because you added that
part and then i have to and you're
absolutely right and then i have to just
add the part about that is that
basically what happened was after world
war ii we entered into the bretton woods
uh uh monetary system right where where
gold
was we were on a gold standard at 35 an
ounce and basically everyone else was on
a dollar standard
because we had all the gold after world
war ii because everyone else was
destroyed and we had all of it so the
deal was
don't worry you can back your currency
with dollars and that's as good as gold
because you can trade that in for gold
anytime you want
and then we cheated and we had the
federal reserve printing tons of money
and
other people started to sniff this out
because basically we were going to the
moon and fighting a war in vietnam and
doing the great society
and other countries were like wait a
minute i don't think you actually have
the gold for this
and england and france i believe it was
called our bluff
and they said okay we're returning all
of our dollars we want our gold and then
in 71
nixon it basically the first great
default
of american debt said no we're not
giving it to you
and you know they spun it in this like
you know they're trying to undermine the
sovereignty of the dollar
thing but really it was like that we
were cheating and we didn't have any of
it so then
our money was backed by nothing so
following that this was kissinger's move
to go
we'll back it with oil and then
basically you still have some type of
commodity standards and then he went to
saudi
because you look at what you know saddam
was saying didn't he want to get off the
dollar for oil
he did gaddafi did a whole bunch of them
they all find themselves on the wrong
side of these wars if they don't want to
play ball
stick yep well so i wonder how much of
what happened during trump's presidency
with saudi arabia and yemen was
him inheriting the problems of the
previous administrations he didn't start
any new wars
he did make mistakes like the missile
strike in syria and hiring bolton
but later on it seems like he was at
least trying you think
he didn't start any new wars he deserves
credit for that for sure
he flirted and got dangerously close in
venezuela and iran
and iran but didn't and and to his
credit
could have and there were a lot of
people around him who wanted those wars
i mean bolton was the national security
adviser
when that stuff with iran was going it
was the only time the mainstream media
praised him oh he actually stopped
criticizing
24 7 non-stop and they were like he's a
great he's a great president he's
showing real leadership
brian williams was literally
family-friendly show
uh releasing liquids from his pants area
when he saw the missiles
flying over into syria that's beautiful
he called it an amazing beautiful
sign of democracy and freedom that's
what they wanted that's what would save
trump if trump was like i'll blow up who
you tell me to
that's right but trump also could trump
could have played it one of two ways and
he just sat in the middle and failed
yes okay so he could have uh fought
another war
and they would have all loved him and if
he had started another war or two
the the establishment would have rallied
around him cnn would have backed him
because that's how sick these people are
they think about it they accused him of
treason when he met with putin
and said hey let's be friends let's be
let's have the two countries who have 90
of the nuclear weapons in the world
let's have some data here let's be
friends
that to them is treason bombing uh
people in third world countries
that's a great president so he could
have done that and won them or
he could have ended every last one of
these wars and won the american people
and he did nothing he sat in the middle
and he lost exactly
and you know what the the issue for the
media was in my opinion
if it bleeds it leads pictures of bombs
war
is shocking content that they can sell
on a slow news day you turn on these
these channels and they give you nothing
i remember watching segments of like
anderson cooper standing in mud and he's
like it's raining here in this part of
the country and i'm like
their ratings are probably in the gutter
yeah but when they get that war and that
shock footage and they say it's a crisis
and
oh and they they try and sell it trump
wasn't giving him
giving the media their bloodlust there's
a lot of other things there's a
political influence
a lot of these networks well yeah i mean
half of their staff are former cia
former nsa former military industrial
complex
if anyone wants to see bloodlust and
suffering all they have to do is go to
yemen
right right so so they had that option
to highlight that
yeah well they weren't interested in it
because that would have that would have
been an indictment of all of them and
the entire system that they prop up
think about what we saw under obama with
extrajudicial assassinations
how much of this when they reported on
the war in the conflict
was were they criticizing obama for it
and how much was it was general coverage
you look at the refugee crisis which was
huge news a couple of years ago
mostly with the eastern mediterranean
route these are people coming from syria
iraq afghanistan etc
and that was the fault of george w bush
and barack obama
and the context of it all was general
news coverage
when it comes to donald trump the dude
could you know step on a twig and it
would crack and they'd all start
shrieking at the top of their lungs
and you know i think it is they they
needed to replace that bloodlust with
something
and because trump wasn't giving them
what they wanted both politically
and in the ratings they turned it into
him they found a way to weaponize it but
it's finally
yeah no i think you're right about that
but i also think that what donald trump
just by his very nature represented
was the refutation of the
the whole system and that that in a way
was a threat to them and also the fact
that they they told everyone well look
we've laid out these rules we represent
the american people we know what they
think they'll never vote for this guy
and then they voted for this guy
and now they all look bad because they
told you this couldn't possibly happen
and the truth is it's like this whole
thing man it's like
it's like levels of irony and tragedy
it's something it's like a greek tragedy
that the country
so hated clinton bush
obama establishment they failed so much
of the country they squandered the
greatest country on earth but the only
thing we had that could actually beat
them
was donald freaking trump and we
everyone
wanted him to be something else like the
left wanted him to be hitler the right
wanted him to be the caesar
yeah and he's just donald trump well so
so i think it was cernovich who said uh
you know like so the left wants him to
be hitler the right wants him to be
caesar
and cernovich said he's a kardashian
yeah
the people looked at what they were
given and they said i'll take donald
trump
think about what that means now i've
long said
the way i view the trump presidency and
why i thought it made more sense to
support him was that you have the ivory
tower
you have the establishment elites
looking down and scoffing and laughing
at the little people as they use
the working-class people's children as
cannon fodder
and they're laughing and then along
comes bernie sanders
left populist and donald trump right
populist and they're banging on the
doors
well they said hey bernie come on up
don't worry we'll be nice to you and he
was like oh gee there look me and
then he joins on in the trump people
broke the door down
trump storms in and he's like a raging
bull knocking things over flipping
tables screaming at everybody and they
were freaking out
oh heavens oh and they're fanning
themselves and running from the tower
and then they desperately needed to get
it back so i look at the trump
presidency as fairly chaotic
we had a really really great economy in
2019 the best numbers of our lives
and i said this in a previous episode
well i i asked i think i asked luke to
try and coax him into saying it
isn't trump our greatest greatest
president of our lifetimes and i'm like
you're like but when you look at no new
wars
and you at least look at the attempts to
withdraw our troops from some of these
places
it is far from perfect but you look at
clinton bush and obama
so he's half as bad as the other ones or
he's uh
as good as he promised to be but again
it's still i think he brought up a good
point
you you bring up the bull analogy but
they also contained him in the lower
level so he couldn't get anywhere else
up and they he
and he he raged but he raged in the gift
shop
he didn't rage in the actual positions
that actually mattered
and in my opinion he kind of like just
put the establishment at half pace
of where they were going anywhere and he
held them back halfway but the
establishment was still moving in
uh fairly fairly close with him and now
they're going to go full steam ahead
with joe biden
and i do think there's going to be new
conflicts uh engaged
all throughout the world specifically
also around russia
they're going to try to kind of also
they're going to bump heads with china
but i think biden has too many ties to
china to actually do anything legitimate
china is going to expand its territory i
think it's very fair to say that
but they're going to be butting heads
very seriously
uh in other places in the world like
ukraine
syria who knows turkey is also a very
hot location
that's in conflict with greece right now
so there's a lot of potential for
conflict all over the world stage and i
think a biden administration is going to
exploit that to the fullest extent
because
he has the top echelons of the
military-industrial complex
in his cabinet in his administration and
you know at the end of the day
they're the ones who are going to be
calling the shots and they do call the
shots
i i i have to wonder about all of these
people who constantly think there's this
grand plan
you know like the like not necessarily
the cue people but the periphery to them
as well
that are like i can see what's happening
their comments i see pop up where
they're
like you know trump didn't really
concede he said a new administration
which means he's replacing pence and
it's like dude
like trump i thought was way better than
hillary clinton
it's not hard to be way better than
hillary clinton she was awful like one
of the worst politicians to ever run
and just this demanding and sickly
individual is just and she wanted it
and we we had a choice between the
establishment over and over and over
again
and there was an opportunity for a trump
and he and he managed to pull it off
well i mean like trump
whatever oh no far from perfect but
whatever criticism you could
you could uh launch at trump and there's
a lot uh
donald trump uh made it
that we didn't have another bush or
clinton and for that alone yeah
for that president he should be saluted
just for beating the bushes and the
clintons and destroying those two
evil you know like uh um family
organizations criminal organizations and
look i'll say this i think uh barack
obama was an absolutely horrible
president but you know what because of
him john mccain wasn't president
and oh my god if you want to see a
disaster let
john mccain have access uh to to be the
commander-in-chief of the military i
mean we'd probably be in five more wars
if he had been there so now obama did
pretty much get
five more this is the main problem
though like i think trump
i i think trump operated in good faith
when he got in he thought that he was
president now and you know people were
going to listen to him and that he was
going to have control and get to do the
things that he wanted
fulfill his promises and these wars and
he didn't realize he was walking into a
gigantic machine all
gummed up with bureaucracy and red tape
okay but that's on him
see the problem but the problem with
donald trump
okay is that he doesn't know
anything about anything there's not
one thing he's ever read a book about
and knows something about it he's got
instincts he's instinctually brilliant
in many ways
but dude he banned critical race theory
being uh
like taught to the military and in
government organizations and through
contracts
because three months ago he was watching
fox news
and saw a thing about critical race
theory and when what's this critical
race theory thing
that sounds stupid let's stop doing it
he had no clue what it was
up until that point so that's the
problem and at the debate he couldn't
define it
yeah yeah oh no no i'll take it yeah
well look i agree
it's still better than nothing but it's
kind of like but dude to rise to the
level
to actually do what he could have done
the person he could have been in history
he needed to know like three things
and he knew nothing i think it's
obviously hyperbole he doesn't know
anything
i think the dude's clearly successful
became president he's very rich and the
problem was he entered government
thinking it would work like a business
he thought he could just fire people he
couldn't do it he surrounded it he hired
bad people and the one thing he was
famous for
firing people he didn't do enough of he
hired people and fired his own people
when he should have been firing all
these holdovers who were going behind
his back leaking information and
sabotaging everything
he overspent that's another thing if he
was running if he was running it like a
business
the business is gravely in debt right
now that our children's children
are going to be paying for and also when
you look at the people he surrounded
himself with
the ones that he took advice from i mean
jared kushner the one who negotiated
better weapons deals for saudi arabia
ivanka
the lady who cried about the alleged
chemical weapons attack in syria that
many investigations proved not to be
true
that convinced him to bomb syria
according to
trump's son who admitted that this
happened i mean come on i mean
no no now i gotta say though i gotta say
you're doing a lot of ragging on the guy
the abraham accords are amazing yeah i
don't think so no i
no fair enough i would just say i was
actually gonna defend him in that moment
too that i will say the one
one defense i'll give to donald trump
for putting his family uh in these
positions that they were not in any way
qualified to be is that
he really had he really had no one he
could trust and they did try to frame
the guy for treason
for three years and he had the entire
deep state working against him so i
think he did want his family there
because he's like okay well at least
ivanka's not going to like be setting me
up for
you know like she set him up to bomb
syria but look for
for all the issues too jared kushner
helped negotiate these historic peace
agreements
yeah look when i think the peace
agreements to be honest i i like the
sound of it i think they're kind of
overplayed
there's not really any meaningful piece
uh between
people who were not already allies it's
like okay you can make this
normalization of
economies new flights not now planes
from from one arabic country can fly
over israel
look it's not an easy good it's not an
easy process so i remember when donald
trump crossed the dmz into north korea
and he was heavily criticized for it and
said all he was doing was endangering
the country and negotiating with a
dictator and i'm like dude
negotiations have to start somewhere
yeah if we get bahrain and the
emirates and uh uh you know now you've
got
uh uh morocco and they're normalizing
relations
that's the first step i listen i agree
that's and and that's more than
what happened for obama but what
happened with the listen you're
absolutely right about the north korea
stuff it was great that he did that it
was amazing it was a great first step
and what happened with those those trade
negotiations
this idiot made john bolton the national
security adviser
and sent him over there to blow the
whole thing yeah and that's
sabotage and that is on trump
of course like who in the right mind
would put this guy but this is another
thing that people really need to think
about donald trump set up a peace deal
that was almost identical to the same
iranian peace deal that he wanted north
korea to have so he ended one piece deal
and he wanted another one that he
unsuccessfully didn't get and we're
gonna have a biden administration that's
going to do the opposite and it's like
they're playing with us they're toying
with us
you know look over here but on the other
end they commit something as we can
clearly see
from these reports assuming that mitch
mcconnell one is true
trump trusted way too many republicans
thinking that they were going to work
with him and what they wanted was judges
and then they gave him bad info bad
people and they just were waiting him
out and now i do believe they want to
purge him
and all of his supporters but like you
said the people still love the man
yeah and i think i think you know why i
think when you listen to him
i think trump does want to help people i
just don't think he understands how
government works
yeah you might be right i don't actually
know what he wants and i gotta say i'm
starting to think more and more that he
really just
wants to help himself um but i will say
that
the donald trump looked at an entire
group of americans
who are just absolutely despised
by the ruling elite i mean they hate
these people
you don't have to watch cnn for more
than 10 minutes to just gauge
what they think of the average trump
supporter they hate these people
they lecture them all day long they
don't care as you pointed out they use
their kids as cannon fodder
they they don't care that there's a drug
they barely even ever report on the drug
ods
on the suicide rate on the life
expectancy going down these people
have been completely screwed screwed
over by the empire just completely
forgot about
and donald trump looked at those people
and said you know what i care about you
i want to bring your jobs back i want to
win for you
and that was enough that was all it took
because no one had ever talked to those
kids before it was like someone
showing like you know like the ugly girl
in high school a little bit of attention
and she was like i
love you like that's okay you're my i
don't mean to insult
anybody i think i just insulted i think
i just alienated trump supporters and
women
i think i lost i don't know who's left
but i'm just making the point
he just he just didn't hate them you
know you'd see these pieces like on cnn
where they'd be like why do these
evangelicals support donald trump and
like kind of on the surface you could
see what they're talking
about i mean clearly the guy's not a
devout christian um
but you know why they support him
because he doesn't
hate their guts and you do and he
doesn't
he eats steak with ketchup and michael
michael moore made those same exact
points that you were missing right now
well that's
this is my favorite story that i
remember when donald trump went to this
fancy restaurant and he ordered like
this 30-day
dry age steak super fancy and expensive
well done
with ketchup and i watched the media
mock
and laugh and you know why that was so
brilliant on trump's part
do you know what the regul what regular
americans saw when they watched those
segments
they weren't mocking and laughing at
trump they were mocking and laughing at
you the regular working-class american
who's got only a couple bucks to buy
that garbage you know steak from the
supermarket
that you cook it all the way through and
you put ketchup on it because it tastes
like crap yeah
so i remember when i was growing up
guess what for the most part yeah we'd
get
you know grocery store cuts for a couple
bucks we'd cook them well we put ketchup
on it because we weren't rich
every so often we'd save up and my dad
would come back with the filet mignon
and like this is the good stuff
and he put a little garlic and salt on
it and we just ate it like it was and it
was so amazing
and so i knew when i saw that story what
trump was doing whether he's all about
expensive well-done steaks with ketchup
or he knew i'm going to speak to these
people who have been kicked to the curb
and insulted and the media walked right
into it yeah
you know you know what it really comes
down to for me the media is despicable
it is it is the press in this country it
is lies all day and every day
and that's and and you know i grew up uh
with the
the war in iraq the lies from the media
the the
this blind trust of government and it
got us into these wars
and there was no accountability for
these people many of whom are still
working these politicians who voted for
it still in office
to 47 years and that's tha and that's
why i say
it's kind of funny to say that donald
trump is the greatest president of my
lifetime
because he didn't vote for these things
he spoke out against them in his book
he did really poorly in hiring any and
he fumbled a lot
but he spoke to the people he did a lot
more than these elites did
he banned critical race theory whether
he knew about it or not i liked it and
it was only in the past
year or so when i was like i like what
i'm seeing right now i like the attempts
at least
to mock the establishment you know what
i really like i'm with you completely on
that but that was a great gift that he
gave us
just relentlessly mocking the corporate
press you ever see you ever see the the
moment where
he comes out and he's like you know by
the helicopter and the press all asking
him questions
and he's like we got a really great deal
saudi arabia is giving us billions of
dollars for all these weapons
and the anti-war left their jaws hit the
floor like
he just comes out and says he you're not
supposed to admit this
it's supposed to be we're here to
support you know security and peace and
trump's like we're getting great money
it's great for the economy
and then when it came to syria when this
when we left troops there got the oil
fields
he just comes out and says it he's like
you know we tried to get the troops out
of syria but i guess they got mad at me
so we just left in there they're
guarding the oil that's what they wanted
and i'm just like tell the people but i
think that's
i think that's a big part of the reason
why he was so despised
uh is that he is this guy that just
is uncontrollable and he blurts things
out
donald trump can't keep a secret if he
wanted to you know there's no aliens
but but it's also why it scared the
bejesus
out of all of these people you know like
donald trump one of the
people wonder why uh you know like john
brennan for example
hated donald trump you ever hear john
brennan on tv you can tell it is a
personal hatred that he has for donald
trump well
listen donald trump when he was running
in 2016
just blurted out okay that
obama armed isis and created that now he
just blurts this out
he's just like you know obama created
isis that was all obama and they're like
what are you talking about you can't say
that and he goes no no no obama created
isis and
saudi arabia he also blamed them for 9
11
now and he said he was going to end the
federal reserve no he said a lot of
these things now
john brennan was the head of the c.i.a
while they were knowingly arming al
qaeda in iraq
also known as treason with a capital t
these are crimes that if you were uh
prosecuted for
the the punishment for treason i believe
last i checked
is death okay so trump is just out there
blurting it out and to trump he's like i
just said it now i move on and now i'm
going to talk about how great my crowd
is he brings flinders
but brennan's sitting there like what
did you just say you're not supposed to
say this and like people
who talk about this are like like i talk
about this but you talk about this and
stuff
but the president of the united states
with his
70 million adoring voters and before
that it was totally ignored i mean we
had whistleblowers we had government
agents we had insiders we had people on
the ground
that were confirming showing videos
showing photos showing documents of
us arms munitions weapons
trucks going directly into the hands of
isis al-nusra and al-qaeda inside of
syria
to do regime change and and this was
proven but this was only talked about in
the alternative press
until michael flynn uh
actually whistleblowed and released a
lot of the information michael flynn of
course was brought in by donald trump
and donald trump was saying this on the
public stage and then we know what
happened to michael
they got rid of him and this is where
the russian narrative comes in
he must be doing this because he's
trying to undermine and damage this
country
but it was look it because a lot of
people look at it on the surface
and they go oh well but the it failed
because they didn't get him you know
they got nothing off the mueller report
there was no one went to jail for
but no it worked right they boxed him in
for three years
so donald trump was running on look
let's make a deal with russia
that way we both have a common enemy in
isis who cares if assad is the
the president of syria like whatever
we'll just leave him there it's worse
when we overthrow these guys anyway
so we'll make a deal we'll make a deal
with russia we'll get out of syria
and then after hearing nothing but
trump-russia collusion
on repeat every day for years well now
trump can't make a deal
with russia because if he went and made
a deal with russia well then that's
proof
that he's colluding with russia so it
worked perfectly and it's all about
the qatar turkey pipeline now i
shouldn't say all about it's a large
component are you familiar with it
yeah yeah i've read a little bit about
it so there was a report from uh the
guardian going back to i think 2012
where they said that a report in 2009
from the u.s
said they wanted that we wanted to have
boots on the ground in syria because
bashar al-assad was blocking
our access to building this pipeline lo
and behold
everything you guys just talked about
remember that that photo of the truck
isis had and it's got like you know what
was it that truck that had the phone
number for like a michigan
auto mechanic i was like how did that
truck get there
that's not that's weird did you ever win
do you ever hear the uh the tape i don't
remember i'm not sure if it was a hot
mic or like a secret recording but
there's the tape of john kerry
talking about the rise of of isis uh is
really interesting uh is he's talking
about it so he comes in
i guess in was in 2013 he became
secretary of state
so as after hillary clinton left um and
he's talking about so this is kind of
you know right as it's happening um and
he's talking about
and he's basically just saying quite
frankly on this tape i think he doesn't
realize he's being recorded
and he's going uh he goes look we saw it
we saw the rise of isis coming
um but we thought we could control it
yeah and use it
to bring assad to the negotiating table
so you also
you got to understand with a lot of
these things it's tremendous hubris
that they think everyone's their pawns
and then because look
it was not part of the plan for isis to
then go
invade iraq have the shiite army that we
trained
bail strip off their uniforms and hand
over all the stockpiled weapons to them
that wasn't part of the plan so they
just think that they can control
everybody
in the same way that like the black
lives matter rioting smashing up that
cnn building wasn't part of the plan
you're like wait you guys weren't
supposed to do that
you were supposed to just go over here
but people are not pawns and it's not
always easy to control them so the whole
thing just got away from that well they
created
the cultural situation in iraq
especially with
the second gulf war after they got rid
of a lot of the hussein
baptist loyalists that they said no
longer could serve in the new military
so a lot of those fighters joined up
with more radical sunnis and they were
enabled to start
this larger group that later became
known as isis directly because of
policy decisions by the bush
administration specifically making sure
uh that that this protocol was followed
it was it led to tremendous amounts of
human suffering i mean
people were tortured on camera with
with amazing like production that was
terrifying the entire world the western
world has been terrified by
adding up the numbers we're getting to
hitler stalin level numbers you're
talking about a million in iraq
half a million in syria it's gonna be a
million in yemen but this is the same
one thing i need to bring up here is
because we had isis literally dominating
the headlines everyone was always
talking about them everyone in the
western world was scared about a
terrorist attack happening in their city
because of them
and their ideas they had the direct
fingerprints of all the upper echelons
of the u.s intelligence agencies
israel saudi arabia working with them in
cohesion and then
all of that just magically kind of went
away under the presidency of donald
trump who
who uh from the information i'm getting
stopped funding them no he's not
supporting that that was you want to
give
trump credit for something that was one
of the first things he did yeah he ended
he ended the cia
program to arm the anti-assad rebels yes
and
almost immediately after that isis just
stopped being a problem and there was
also and they also fought him i mean
it was like the russians were fighting
them and our troops were well the
russians were exposing
they were selling oil syrian oil to
turkey
and so so let me ask you then because
kind of going back to we're talking
about trump's presidency in this country
do you think that like regular military
folk
not the high-ranking officers and the
political actors but just like
your you know rank-and-file maybe
lower-level officers do you think
they'll support the president
yes i think the vast majority of them do
and i but you also have to understand i
mean look
uh ron paul when he ran in 2008 and 2012
got more money from active duty military
than every other candidate combined both
years
the so anybody who's talking about
ending these wars
is going to get tremendous support from
the rank and finally
they know way better than us about how
crazy these wars bush
obama trump all promised we're going to
end all the wars we're going to bring
all the troops back all of them yeah
even george w bush
oh yeah no that's right yeah he's like
i'm going to be a non-interventionist
president
elect me we're going to keep america at
home and we're going to make sure
america is great
let me jump to this next story we'll
kind of bring all of this foreign policy
stuff back home because we have this
report from the daily mail
joint chiefs send memo to all u.s troops
condemning
maga riots as sedition after arrest of
current
and retired officers and spell out that
they only follow lawful orders in fresh
warning to trump
they say the military's top leaders
issued a written reminder to all service
members tuesday
that the deadly insurrection at the
capitol was a criminal act the memo
signed by all members of the joint
chiefs of staff
also reminded military members that joe
biden was duly elected as the next
president
it comes after the arrest of current and
retired
officers among the riders among the
known retired veterans who stormed the
capitol was ashley babbitt
a retired air force veteran who was shot
dead retired lieutenant colonel larry
lieutenant colonel larry rendell brock
jr 53
was slapped with federal charges after
he was pictured carrying plastic
handcuffs
in the capitol during the riot the army
is also investigating a psychological
warfare officer
captain emily rainey for leading a group
of people from north carolina to the
rally
so this i found interesting that it
turns out even the uh the horned viking
guy
navy veteran yeah there were a lot of
people there who served
and you've also got the oath keepers
many of them who have served many of
them who are still police officers now
clearly support the president and i
guess the question is
does the like the military
overwhelmingly support the president
would they support him
you know moving forward well that's
that's the big fear i mean i'm literally
just as
as you're reading that i'm thinking of
the um you know the the smedley butler
yeah yeah that plot i mean you know who
they were going to use for that
was all the these veterans from world
war one i mean that's who that because
if you
if you actually wanted like what would
your big fear be if you were the
establishment
and that that would be your fear so you
better get that under control yeah and
that fear is
real because why else would they be
sending out a memo to all the branches
of
the military that's the point you know
you know why are they doing this if
they're not worried about something
or other branches of the military uh
potentially deciding or thinking about
doing something well
when when those polls came out before
the election saying that the military
overwhelmingly supported joe biden i
just didn't believe it i laughed
i was like come on why would first of
all
i i i've not served um my family
has most most of them and my family have
in some way been involved in you know
the armed forces
but i did live briefly on a military
base i do know many people
so i don't want to speak for them but i
kind of feel like
the amount of respect they'd have for
someone like biden who is a career
politician
enriched himself off the office and
votes for the wars that gets
you know them sent out i don't think
they're going to be like that's the guy
i pick
and not only that you look at what trump
says about the troops what he does for
them
and how he advocates for them and i just
feel like it makes no sense
so i asked some people you know do you
think because there was a uh
a statement put out in the washington
post by all uh former defense
secretaries
warning members of the military not to
follow trump's orders
they were like do not well it was it was
interesting because this is a
it's getting close to a military coup
when you have these individuals
telling the military not to obey trump
if he gives them orders to do something
but they wouldn't like like you were
just saying they wouldn't need to put
that statement on the washington post
all former living ex-secretaries of
defense saying don't do this
you will go to prison this is for you to
chris miller of the pentagon
now you have this statement where
they're saying to all the members of the
military it was it was a riot
know it joe biden's president it's done
why are they saying it now that's kind
of freaky
yeah why do they need to say it well
they're definitely concerned
i mean this was one of the big things
about donald trump in general that
really
like scared the establishment and i
think this is the reason why
he scares them a lot more than bernie
sanders does even though bernie sanders
did scare them
is that donald trump's supporters are
just
way tougher like if you had to fist
fight a random bernie sanders fan or a
random donald trump fan
you would not for a second like i mean
let's just be real people here you would
immediately go i'll i'll take on three
bernie sanders fans if i have to fight
them
rather than one donald trump because
donald trump probably has some barrel
chested minor or something like that
he's gonna pound you into a bloody mess
and bernie sanders is like some gender
studies major
hold on one other point that i wanted to
make to your kind of question
another thing that is really relevant
here is that joe biden is one of the
first
presidents that didn't really address
the war question at
all yeah he's not anti-war right a lot
of people know this a lot of foreign
policy experts are saying he's most
likely going to start more conflicts
and he's going to have the continued
american foreign policy that was just
halfway under donald trump also during
the blm riots he took the side of
blm rather than police officers so a lot
of people serving
in law enforcement in in the military
know
that he's on the side of the of the
radical protesters
he's entering joe budden is entering the
presidency with probably the least
amount of confidence from
our men and women in uniform and law
enforcement right now well the few
people that we talked
to that voted for him all regret voting
for him you know there's other thought
thinkers like naomi wolf that are like
why did i vote for him i was thinkers
i thought uh thought leaders sorry yeah
i'm dyslexic i'm polish i got hit in the
head a lot when i was a kid
so yeah naomi wolf that was funny yeah
sure that was what did you say if i had
known that joe biden was in favor of
lockdowns i never would have voted for
him
and it's like he's he's he says it all
the time could have known that
geez yeah that's kind of inexcusable to
nada to not know that
but you're right and it's also just that
look joe biden
just basically limped i mean
out of the primaries i mean just kind of
survived them
and was basically um he he almost
won it by process of elimination like
the establishment basically
trotted out all these different people
they were like hey everybody get excited
about warren get excited about buddha
judge get excited about uh you know who
have kamala harris and none of them
caught fire
and then bernie sanders was doing for
and they were terrified of him so they
were like he's no deal and then they
they threw bloomberg out there who just
completely fell apart in the debates and
then they were like
okay i guess all we have left is biden
they had the coordinated hit
where all of biden's competition dropped
out sanders competition and warren
stayed in
they got him over the finish line and
then he basically ran
on being not trump not campaigning well
like nothing we've ever seen before he
didn't run
well right yeah he hit in his basement
and he said i'll just stay away from
this
and and look and that is to some degree
it's like the quality about trump that
got him to the dance is also the thing
that got him out of the dance is that
he does have this personality that he
was willing to say
every nasty thing to everyone around in
order to really beat them
but that also turned a lot of people off
so it was like a double-edged sword
and it was enough for biden binds like
the press will carry me that social
media came down and silenced you know
the big hunter biden story the big
october surprise basically got squashed
and that got him over there but we've
never really had a president like that
not in my lifetime
who won that way obama inspired his way
into the white house
you know i mean it trump inspired his
way into the white house
even this guy was in there with the help
of social media tech oligarchs and the
mainstream media overlords that are like
hey
you're going to represent us you're
going to work for us he's like
he's not even saying yes he's like good
where he's in there like
joe can we count on you to do as you're
told
come on man i've been doing as a toad
for 47 years uh-huh just tell me what to
do i'll go to sleep in the corner and
you can
write my name for me that's essentially
what's going to happen especially when
you see the special interest
the corporatists the banks uh the the
complexes behind them that are
essentially going to be setting american
policy
fast forward in in a way that we have
never seen lobbyists
take control of our government he's a
huge lobbyist he even argued with barack
obama about the power of lobbyists and
how great they are and how we need more
of them
barack obama even ignored even argued
with them against that let's jump to
this story real quick real quick from
the daily mail
4 000 armed patriots plan to surround
congress to stop trump impeachment law
enforcement reveals at closed-door
briefing they say rep conor lamb
revealed tuesday
law enforcement briefed lawmakers on a 4
000 person group of armed patriots
prepared
to prevent democrats from entering the
capital as they move to impeach donald
trump
the threats we are facing are very
specific lamb said tuesday
is more national guard are deployed to
d.c they have published rules of
engagement
meaning when you shoot and when you
don't shoot this is an organized group
that has a plan
in their minds they are patriots so this
this is how we
so this is now a contest of wills trump
declared a state of emergency monday
night
that allows the department of homeland
security and federal emergency emergency
management agency to coordinate with
local authorities on monday night new
chiefs of capitol police told house
democrats they were looking into three
separate plans to hold protests
including one described as largest armed
protest ever to take place on american
soil
but the most concerning is said to
involve armed riders encircling the
capital and blocking democrats from
entering
killing if necessary so that republicans
are able to take command of government
i i don't believe it yeah i mean i mean
i mean maybe but let me put it this way
you mean to tell me that there's a large
group of people
defending trump defying trump that i
don't quite understand
i have i've listened to what the trump
supporters have said
and they are repeatedly saying trump
never said storm the capital
trump was still speaking at the event
when they
already started breaching the barricades
and then trump said we will p we
said we're going to peacefully march and
then cheer on politicians
that was already going down at the
capitol while trump was speaking
so i wonder if the people who were there
probably a lot of them were trump
supporters
but there are elements of the right that
don't much care for trump
they may be you know i'll put it this
way there are people who are trump
supporters first
trump says go home in peace trump
probably could have issued stronger
statements but trump says we condemn the
violence you know go there peacefully
cheer on protesters there are people who
listened
you have this captain uh emily i believe
her name is emily rainey who's being
investigated we just mentioned her
and she said she went there to hear
trump speak and then they all got in
their buses and left
there there was that musician uh i was
named ariel pink who said i went to hear
him speak and then i went to
went down my hotel went to sleep these
are the people who like trump who listen
to him
and when trump says you know go in peace
they do
but then there are other people who are
not trump supporters first they're
something else so they go to the capitol
they engage in this
i have to wonder now when when they're
saying they want to help republicans
take control of government
who are these people that are willing to
put themselves on the line for mitch
mcconnell i don't i don't buy that yeah
it seems very hard uh it seems very hard
to believe i mean i suppose it's not
impossible i
it doesn't seem likely to me there there
seems to be no
there's no strategy there there's no way
this could possibly work
i also do think that they are really
trying to
like their one of the things that the
establishment are
experts at is exploiting a crisis like
they're
so when this thing with the capital
building happens there you can see their
eyes get wide
like okay now we jump on this and now
what they're using
is this argument which is what the
articles of impeachment were uh
you know going to be that he incited an
insurrection that he's inciting violence
now
certainly you can say that donald trump
by claiming the election was stolen got
a lot of people very worked up and maybe
that that
made them more willing to do something
than they would be but you could also
say
that framing the the president uh for uh
as a guilty of treason and a russian
asset
that that would incite some violence you
could certainly say that some of the
people
on the left who have basically been
saying for years now that
uh cops are out there hunting black
people for sport
and i'm no fan of the cops but it's
obviously just a lie
and that that definitely incited a lot
of violence obviously maxine waters
but they only want to apply trump the
double standard i'm just i got to be
honest
it's like every day i see something
about the media the lies the double
standards and i'm just like
i think we all know and anybody anybody
who's saying otherwise is lying
they're just flying so listen i think
it's possible that there's a large group
of people that are angry
but i think these are it's the
equivalent of the people who voted
against trump
there are angry people who probably
don't care about trump and are against
biden
so it's it's entirely possible there's a
large group of people who have crazy
plans
and i don't know where this is coming
from there's reports of like
armed capital protests and like a a
inauguration protest
i've not seen those things i've only
seen trump supporters denounce or deny
them or warn people not to do it yeah
but i'll say regardless
you know people should not be going and
going down to dc i think the
inauguration
the what the what they're planning is it
seems
a tad bit reckless but i definitely
think they need to up security to an
extreme degree
i mean the last in dc for the time being
the last thing we need is any kind of
escalation
it's the worst possible thing it's going
to result in nothing but bloodshed if
they were to do something like that and
it will
it will serve the opposite of what your
interest is if you hate this
like kind of government authoritarian
control
yes this would be the best thing for
them you can do you cannot win a show of
force with the federal government
don't kid yourself into thinking you
will if you ever got to the point where
it actually threatened them in some way
they will go waco style on you and burn
children alive to protect their
interests
don't do it do not the way to fight the
federal government
has to be done through peaceful means
right now it's the most militarized
government in human history
you want to do something if you're in
like a red district
in a rural red area start teaching
prayer in school again
that way do something like that not even
about that it's about
we've mentioned it several times we're
in the information warfare era where the
information age
winning influence comes through
confident arguments and playing the game
strategically
a lot of these trump supporters like
talk about 4d chess well i think y'all
should be playing it right now
because look at what they're already
doing because some people
storm to the capital now that's crazy
the zip tie guy some of this stuff's
crazy
should not have been done but compare
that to the waves of damage and
destruction we've seen throughout the
last year with black lives matter okay
now to act like
you know aoc goes on uh once you go on
abc saying half of congress is on the
verge of being killed or whatever and
it's like oh calm down
calm down but you can see how they
weaponize it yeah it was it was one of
the dumbest things people could have
done well you can't
you can't copy the the techniques of the
left because they
essentially have the mainstream media
social media and a lot of the larger
kind of cultural sports
uh spokespeople that essentially send
out these larger ideas that kind of
justified
lydia sent us a video before about what
happened to
rand paul recently where he was walking
through a crowd and blm protesters
surrounded him
and uh you know with his wife with his
wife in a
very tense situation but there was no
outrage by the mainstream media
they were screaming at him about briana
taylor exactly even though he
sponsored the bill for brianna taylor
exactly so so there's always
so we got to understand there's crazy
and there's bad actors in every group
like we understand yeah but the kind of
thing that i'm worried about and if i
could be allowed to speculate i don't
like to speculate but we know
if we let politicians gain more power
from emergencies
what's stopping them from creating
emergencies to gain more power
and with everything coming up forward i
have this kind of
feeling that there might potentially be
either another
grave escalation that could be planned
and organized or maybe even a false flag
but this is just something that i
personally feel
that we should keep an eye out for
because i think there's a huge potential
to turn this already horrible situation
to turn it
i'll i think a lot worse than it is i
think talk of false flags
is just going to help them more if if
it's true that they want the emergency
then they will love to hear you claiming
that they were the ones who were behind
it so they can say now you're crazy
and these people are crazy no look there
are crazy people
and i i've seen people post crazy stuff
online i have heard
crazy stuff from some of the craziest
you know trump supporting
there are some stories out there reuters
at a store where they interviewed a guy
who said
just if trump just says the word no no
no we don't want any of that trump's
word was go in peace and he condemned
the violence
yeah the strategy now is it's
propagandistic it's persuasion
it's culture its influence the daily
wire put out this movie
that's what conservatives need to be
doing that's the battlefield right now
the hearts and minds of the people
i'm not reporting not going and trying
to fight like you said the most
militarized government what we need to
do is try to de-escalate
some of the crazies the bad actors but
you and
you don't de-escalate by shunning them
and attacking them and putting them in a
corner where they get to grow and fester
and and not have their bad ideas
challenged
so whether it's bad actors or radicals
on the left or right we have to
understand that this area
of censorship you're essentially
creating more radicals
and more people on the floor you're
absolutely right about that and this is
what always happens like even on an
individual level right like
psychologically speaking it's like
repression and then it comes back out in
some worse form that's why you don't
want to repress
you know like negative feelings um but i
i do think if you're going to understand
all these crazy people acting this way
if you're going to understand the year
that was 2020 and now into 2021
and all the craziness you really can't
understand it outside the context of the
lockdowns
i mean it's like this is it's not a
coincidence that people are acting
so freaking crazy over the last nine
months
that just happened to be the time when
we the government
locked people in their homes shut down
everything put them in a state of
paranoia and fear
about a floating abstraction of a germ
about their economic security about
their their children's future people are
they've driven people crazy there's
there's something that i'm
i i will now call lockdown derangement
syndrome
and what i mean by this is there are
people that i know who have gone insane
like no joke and what i think happens is
you
take a couple of people lock them in a
room and
strip them away from all social
communications and what happens is
let's say you have three people persons
a b and c person a
says something he says one then person
two one up someone says two
three four five six they keep escalating
the insanity between them
so i've seen this before when i was
younger there was a group of people that
i knew
that all they would do is hang out in
their room and play video games all day
and complain
about a person they didn't like until it
went from one day
where we knew they kind of didn't like
this dude and then a month later they
were like
like on the verge of attacking him and
beating him because all they did was
rile themselves up
there are people that i know who have
been locked up for months that have
literally just snapped
talking crazy conspiracies you've got
the q people on the right but you've got
equal elements of this on the left
who just have wound themselves up into
psychotic
lockdown conspiracies because they've
had no communication with regular people
to normalize those yeah dude you're
absolutely right dude have you ever like
had
you know like we probably all had this
right like in the last like four or five
years or something where you could be
like you know like on a youtube
journey or on twitter or something like
that and you're literally you know
you're hearing like some crazy woke
leftist and then you see like some white
nationalist alt writer type and you see
like all these videos and you're like oh
my god this country's like on the verge
of a race war
but then you go to the supermarket and
like some black guy walks in front of
you and he's like oh pardon me and
you're like no go ahead sir you're fine
yeah and then you're like
you know what i think we're fine i think
but like if you just and so when people
are just isolated and it's just the
mediums of like youtube and twitter and
this
it's easy to start losing perspective we
lost that
that illusion we lost that reality
because we no longer
are social creatures and we need to be
social and the less social we are the
less better off
we are as human beings especially with
our mental health
with our physical health we are meant to
be uh
community oriented individuals that's in
our dna that's how we pretty much were
our entire existence the way i describe
it is right now
so i i mentioned this couple times but
this past weekend i did
less content and it's because every time
i would open up twitter
it would just be like opening an app and
then screaming
that's all it was people saying like
it's insurrection it's addition it's
terror
you know purge the criminals they should
be locked up and i'm like dude
shut up it is not the apocalypse ted
cruz is not a traitor
calm down but they won't stop
they have they have gone insane they've
been isolated for too long
and the only winner to the world they
have is the screaming
face in their like the phone just
screaming at them the whole time
or a government that in los angeles now
is telling them to wear masks
inside of their own they're going insane
they're getting the crazy thing to me is
what this has really exposed and has
surprised me is the lack of mental
fortitude
among the average person in this country
which i must say right now i have
overestimated most of my life
and now what i'm starting to realize is
that a lot of people break down much
more quickly than i realized i don't
blame them for doing it
yeah but without other humans to
interact with people snap
i think start making crazy things i
think i uh i agree with you and i i
think i also
underestimated the importance of some of
the things that i probably thought of as
trivial
you know like just like sports or your
bar something that you might look at is
just like oh whatever this is just kind
of a stupid waste of time anyway and
then you're like
no actually maybe it's really important
maybe people really need that like
you know that like going to a football
game and going to a bar and like doing
these these silly things that americans
do
but that actually do keep us human in
some way and when you take that
all away from everybody um things get
pretty ugly i mean look when the when
the black lives matter riots first
started
that was the only game in town yeah
there was literally nothing else open
and there was nothing you could do but
you could go wrong you couldn't go
outside
yeah but you could go out and riot right
i mean so it was almost kind of like and
then i'm trying you're thinking about it
and you're like well look a lot of these
are like kids you know i mean maybe like
young 20s or something but they're kids
and i think back to like me like now i'm
like in my mid-30s i'm a father i'm kind
of in a different place but
i imagine what taking away hanging out
would have been to me suicides were
spiking but look what happened when
people were on lockdowns who were they
held captive by they were held captive
by their phones by social media which
has a historical trend of showing
a direct correlation with the
destruction of people's mental health
there's a direct rise there's a direct
correlation with the advent of the
social media atmosphere with of course
mental health going down in so many
different ways in so many different
categories that's absolutely terrifying
and now you're locked down and forced to
just be on that one
single institution that's controlled by
some oligarchs that fine-tune what you
see and what you don't see
i mean that's a lot of power and then
these individuals are coming to us now
saying
just give us more power it's okay we're
gonna keep you safe guys
as they destroy and rot mental health
for the last decade
they're doing it now in an extreme level
we need to tell people if you're
listening
meditate that's what i was saying
earlier you know this weekend
i did a segment and then we we drove
like an hour and a half onto the middle
of nowhere
went to a lake no cell service started a
little fire with some rocks and just
chilled there was some ice on the lake
we threw rocks at it it was a whole lot
of fun
you know luke's dog was running around
getting all wet and being all silly
and we couldn't connect to the internet
and i thought it was just great
looking around at the emptiness and the
beauty of nature
and just calming down you know my other
ideas maybe
we should create an app that is twitter
but when you open it it screams
so you don't want to be looking at
you're like i want to check twitter but
it's going to be really
loud i'm screaming and insults you and
cursing
i'll tell you this man i i'm half joking
when i say it but i said here's my
compromise for all the
censorship just ban social media just
get rid of it
it's made people gonna go insane it's
it's look
the grifter thing is real there are
grifters there are people who have built
careers off just saying the most
inflammatory thing possible to get
followers
and then the funny thing is you have you
have the like
the second layer the grifter who accuses
the other person of being a grifter
creating grifter loop feedback or then
they make money off accusing the other
person
and it is just a psychotic it is it is a
psycho
psycho producing machine where people
lose their minds
out of context clips clips that can't be
put in context because twitter only
allows a number of characters anyway
and then people go on twitter for news
and commentary and opinion
and they're going nuts seeing the worst
of humanity highlighted on a highlight
reel showing you
don't trust other person they're gonna
get you sick they're gonna they're gonna
steal from you they're gonna rob from
you they're gonna hurt you don't trust
anyone around you
your corporate overlords will tell you
what to do just serve them blindly and
everything will be fine that's
essentially the larger message that's
being put out there
by your social media feed but people
don't even realize so here's the thing
though
it is it has often been said and let me
let me know if you disagree
that the right knows what the left is
thinking the left doesn't know what the
right is thinking
the right thinks the left is misguided
the left thinks the right is evil
and i've noticed that my friends who are
very left when they watch news the only
videos of trump supporters they see are
the worst
of the worst they've not interacted with
trump supporters you know why it makes
sense
they don't live in these air in these
areas trump supporters they're all over
the place
but many in more suburban and rural
areas people who live in cities
are in cubicles locked up and they can't
get out and they're not going to bump
into a trump supporter for the most part
and if they do they wouldn't admit it
so they don't know they see a video of
like you know some crazy
fat redneck guy screaming about how he
refuses to wear masks and he's spitting
on people and they're like that's trump
and his supporters
not realizing that you also have like
little old soccer mom who's just going
out to buy a gallon of milk who's also
voted for trump and supports him a great
deal
they don't know that so i see these
people on the left completely clueless
and assuming everyone on the right
is the is pure evil and then i see on
the right they understand
that there are just mindless what they
call default liberals
so bridging that gap is is the problem
but i think it already comes down to
once again the media
you've got people who just blindly trust
the mainstream media and you have people
who don't
so how does this work well the people
who are watching or listen to this
podcast
have sought it out they've gone to
youtube they searched for it
someone recommended it they decided to
check it out
on the other side you have people who
just turn on cnn and whatever wolf
blitzer says is law
if you're only listening to the likes of
cnn you're probably going insane
if you're going on youtube and seeking
out content it's possible there's a lot
of people who found crazy channels went
crazy too
but you're more likely to get a
different array of content on youtube
but people were shaped people were
groomed by these new algorithms whether
by youtube or by facebook who
started to work with quote authoritative
sources
and slowly but surely people started
getting more wolf blitzer
more anderson cooper and less the
average person that's them
that doesn't work average person that
that that is like them that that shares
an idea that's unique
that's not a question it's not working
on youtube youtube
has created like you know special
authoritative sources and they're all
thumbs down into oblivion why
you cannot take an inquisitive person
and feed them fake news and have them
accept it
they watch wolf blitzer and they go well
this is wrong i'm not gonna watch this
and then they come to this
show by by the very nature of the
structure the people who are watching
your show
want to think and the people who are
watching wolf blitzer's show want to be
told what to think but think about it
it's just kind of like the type of
person you get there and so if you get
the type of person
that's interested in your show and you
try to give them that it's just not
going to work
but i do think that look you're right
about what you said about the right
understanding the left more than the
left understands the right there's
actually like scientific studies that
can demonstrate that pretty conclusively
but i think the big problem that's
staring everyone in the face
in america right now that we're either
going to fall apart or find a way to
work through
is that and i think on some level
everybody knows this that
this whole thing doesn't work anymore
and from my perspective now i'll
admit this is my bias i'm a libertarian
but from my perspective
the big central problem here is that the
government got
way too powerful and way too big and
when you have
this much power rooted in washington dc
now the fact that we have drastically
different cultures in the country which
has always been true
brooklyn and alabama have never been the
same thing you know what i mean but now
it's this huge center of power that
really was tremendously built up in the
bush and obama and trump years
and now one side gets control of it and
rules over the other side or the other
side gets control and rules over the
other side so now you have to fight
a civil war over who gets control of
this every five years yes and at a
certain point
americans are going to have to say do we
really want to do this anymore
because the only alternative to this is
some form of decentralization
so it could be as drastic as secession
where we just go hey we don't need to
all be one country i mean we hate each
other's guts
why are we a country what are we
benefiting from from being in a country
with
like one side looks at the other side as
baby murderers and the other side looks
at the other side as nazis it's like
okay so why are we together would you
ever be in a friendship with someone who
you thought that about
or the other answer short of secession
is just decentralization
to scale back the power of the central
federal government
allow state and local governments to
have more authority
let peop understand we all have to
accept that in portland
they're not going to live the same way
that they do in florida and
lots of other examples and that's why it
won't work
because california is inviting of
non-citizens into the country
and there are porous borders between
california and the surrounding states
and that means that if you live in say
nebraska you have a very real
uh threat to your laws if there are
people who can enter easily so let's say
nebraska says we don't allow you know
illegal immigration
they can enter in easily through
california there's no security and they
can easily pass from there into another
state and then come to nebraska
so then what do we get do we get state
borders where are they checkpoints well
no it all depends on the employment laws
some countries benefit from literally
what i would say is akin to human
slavery and allow immigrants to come in
and work for pennies on the dollar
other states don't allow it and say hey
if you don't if you're not a citizen you
can't really work here
and they don't incentivize this kind of
corporate slavery of of the immigrant
class
that essentially in my opinion exploits
them and creates a lose-lose situation
for everyone
well all you have to do honestly is not
make it illegal to discriminate
so you just have to get rid of laws that
like you don't need these force
association laws and you can basically
just say that like look people have a
right to discriminate
and not let certain people into their
communities hire them at their
businesses not and now
under current situations you'll have big
fat lawsuits but you'd have to get rid
of that stuff
but the pitch to california would have
to be something like look
you guys can have everything you want if
you're your own state
i mean you got the votes for all of it
now the problem they're going to have is
it's all going to fall apart none of
it's going to work which they've already
experienced with like their
train system and the medicare for all
proposals and everything like it just
doesn't work
but you're going to the only way i
understand you're saying it's just not
going to work and and you're right
there's there's a lot of reasons to
think it's not going to work
but this isn't going to work either what
we're currently doing and so you have to
almost go like
well look the pitch has to be
how much more of this can we keep doing
because by the way look
trump the next trump might be 10 times
worse than donald trump
he might actually be what the left
thought donald trump was you know like
the likelihood that a republican as we
know today wins in
four years i think is slim what will end
up happening is the republican in four
years will be kind of like a center-left
individual by today's standards so you
well i should say
by a true center-left individual and
it's because
if someone like trump let's say we got
somebody who had very very similar
policies
but was not uh you know abrasive and was
very charismatic
the media would annihilate them they
would say it's a smooth talking lie
just another nazi look his policy is the
same as trump it would never work
so what's consistently happened is that
the right has been being is being pulled
left
every way because they're desperate to
appease the media
well that's not the right as much as it
is the republican establishment but
that's very true for the republican
establishment and this is why
they're they're smoked it's not because
of trump
that trump didn't destroy the
republicans trump brought a whole bunch
of new people into the republican party
trump just got them more votes than
they've ever gotten on a presidential
ticket so it's not it's not that trump
destroyed the party
the problem is that the republican party
deserves to be they they have
nothing to stand on right like like what
can the republic what
does mitch mcconnell stand right if you
if you take trump out of the picture
what what is the republican party can
they say that they what have they
conserved
have they have they protected the
constitution do they have do they have
claim to the bill of rights
do they have claim to limited reducing
the deficit right
do they have any claim to small
government do they have any claim to
tradition of any sense cultural
tradition they stand for what the left
stood for 10 years ago that's
all they ever stand for there's none of
them would have the courage
to oppose gay marriage by the way i'm
not i'm for gay marriage i'm not saying
they should i'm just saying
they don't have a claim to anything look
at look at
mccain and you know mitt romney and we
go back all those years and where their
stances were on cultural issues
and now look where the republican party
is today for i think there's good things
because i agree
like i'm for gay marriage and i'm for
you know freedoms and civil liberties
and things like that
i actually lean left a lot on on social
issues too
i just think the woke left is
particularly authoritarian about it but
one of the things jack murphy brings up
is that it was the republican party
accepting gay marriage that allowed him
to actually vote republican
and support donald trump in four years
oh there will be a republican i'm sure
and they will be substantially more
progressive and more woke
than anyone today in fact they probably
will be to a certain degree woke
they'll probably be kind of like me
where it's like they used to be a
liberal
they're kind of left on some issues but
they're called far right
yeah and they'll still get attacked and
destroyed in the media i don't see how
they'll actually win
even if they do move left well the left
made a very important strategic move by
aligning themselves with big tech and
saying you guys could do whatever you
want
but you got to work with us and they do
work in tandem in such a way
that's it's even entangled with the cia
but again you made a very good point
the republicans are pretty much
democrats 10 years ago and the bigger
point you made is the common sense
solution to all of this if you have the
big
government just decentralize it let
people live
how they want to live individually
because when you have a government that
has enough money to give to other
countries
that means they're taking too much money
away from their taxpayers they're too
powerful and and they should
be scaled to size where people get to
have their individual
expression of liberty their individual
expression of culture do what you want
to do if you're california if
you're new york city but if you're
alabama let alabama do alabama
let's do whatever they want to do here's
here's the problem the people who live
in give me a red state texas right a
large portion
don't want abortion to be legal right
issues like that
they say abortion is murder it is
violence and they won't allow that in
their country so they will continue to
fight at the federal level
for supreme court justices to overturn
what they view as
abhorrent and what should be illegal
activity the left will say
we can't allow them the controls of
federal government over everybody listen
but the federal government could just
say it's a state issue no they can't
because the left will say
the right will say we are not going to
allow new york to murder babies
yeah but you know what i don't think
you're right about that because the
right has been
losing for so long that just
allowing texas to ban abortion would be
such a huge win for them
there's already it's like yeah guys
either way they can murder babies in new
york
okay but at least now under this system
they're not going to be murdering them
in your area now and you know what i
think that would actually please a lot
of right-wing people in texas
and yeah it would piss off left-wing
people in new york they would still go
for the reigns of federal power to tell
texas what to do
yes probably because that's in the
[ __ ] because the federal government
incentivizes
uh mindset if the federal government
doesn't incentivize it and doesn't say
we're going to rule for everyone
then it's a state-by-state issue and
individuals could say i want to live in
new york city where i have these
freedoms or i want to live in texas
where i have these different freedoms
but we should focus on protecting
freedom
but rather than limiting listen i
completely agree with you but i also
think that this is getting to a point
where this is less like an ideological
preference or a suggestion
and this is more like a doctor telling
you you need a blood transfusion yes now
you might say like well i don't know how
we're gonna get this blood transfusion
it might be hard to do it's like okay
well you're gonna die
like this is not a joke this country is
on a suicide mission right now
and everybody knows that this isn't a
game anymore it's i remember back in the
in the ron paul days
right ron paul used to always basically
say that i mean those weren't his words
but he would basically say
this country's on a suicide mission like
this is an unsustainable path it wasn't
just like
look i'm a libertarian and i have this
ideology and i think we should all live
this way
he was telling you that this system is
doomed to fail
and back then even when he convinced me
of it it was still kind of an
abstraction it was a concept
now we're seeing it we're watching it
this country is on a suicide mission
and this is the only solution to it so
we have to
try somehow to move in that direction
because the truth is
what you were saying about a right wing
or a republican winning
you're right and you make good points
but the we are going to go in a populist
direction one way or the other for the
simple reason
that this type of corruption that just
screws over the average person so much
always leads to populism
yeah you can't that what we just had
this last year was the biggest transfer
of wealth from the middle class to the
upper
upper class in human history i mean it's
just been an attack on small businesses
and
massive bailouts for big corporations
big banks um they're all doing
integration of our currency
well and that and that goes right along
with the same trend i mean when the new
money gets created it always goes to the
top first and they get all of the wealth
they extract wealth from the poor in the
middle class and when you have that
scenario
of course someone like bernie sanders or
someone like trump who speaks to the
average guy that hey let's take this
whole thing on and win
for you even if they both have some
idiotic ideas of how to do that
that's always going to be popular and
then what that requires is more
government suppression in order to
suppress the populist voices
so we're going to be in this cycle
that's going to kill us in
less we decentralized well they milked
this country to the tune of 28
trillion there's no going back from that
the larger economic ramifications are
terrifying the way i view what's been
happening is
we're two sides continually trying to
build a tower
to see in the other direction right let
me mention it this way you've got two
buildings
and the people on top are like i want to
see the other side i want to see the
mountains well i want to see the ocean
so the left builds a little higher and
now they can see the ocean so the ride
says well now i can't see so they keep
going up
eventually the towers are getting so big
they're starting to sway back and forth
and the bigger they get the more they
sway the more violent it becomes and
eventually they both snap
and collapse and crush under their own
weight that's what's happening if this
escalation keeps occurring until someone
finally says i'm going to stop but you
know what people aren't going to stop
you know why
i believe in freedom free expression
individual liberties individual rights
the constitution
i don't like authoritarianism be it from
corporations or the government
and there are people on the left who
think the government should
mandate what people do because the
planet is doomed they think we're on a
collision course
with the planet the planet's going to
explode and so they're willing to
destroy your life and sacrifice you for
the greater good it's a very utilitarian
versus deontological
argument you have people on the left
saying the needs of the many outweigh
the needs of the few
and then you have many people on the
right saying any act against an
individual in a moral act that cannot be
you know uh conducted so ultimately what
that leads to is one side saying i will
not let you destroy this planet
and the other side's saying i will not
let you oppress individual rights
no one is going to back down from that
fight would you say you know what
in the interest of peace i will allow
the left to continue their expansion
of authority and wokeness and and then
all that
they're doing it now well i mean so you
would what's the actual but what's the
actual proposal there
so in the interest of peace would i say
that
portland can go as woke as they want to
as long as they don't
know what's that on the rest of the
country no that they take the rest of
the country over
and instill their ideology over everyone
else no fighting no that
that i think needs to be fought against
i mean because they said that same thing
they
yeah you see the point yeah why would i
say
to the woke authoritarian communist
types that i'm going to let them
oppress people i won't i'll say look
in portland i've actually where i was
earlier the year in the year was like
shut it down that's crazy and now i'm
kind of like
it's portland they voted for it they
must want it who am i to intervene
but to in to to put that in the rest of
the country to see the woke left call
for the things they're calling for
when they're like it's it's the most
it's the craziest thing when i hear them
say
all we want to do is give the right
wingers health care but they're so dumb
they don't understand it it's like no
maybe you don't understand
they don't want to live by your rules
yeah look i'm with you okay and it's uh
it's kind of like it's the challenge is
daunting
you know what i mean and it's like but
it's worth attempting and to me
what you mean like a peaceful yes right
the only option that we have
is to as we were talking about before
that a military confrontation with the
most militarized government ever is not
going to work and it will just lead to
bloodshed all we have is the power of
ideas
and the truth is that there is
still a remnant of decency in the human
spirit
and a lot of people are there is a huge
movement of people
who are turned off by by the woke stuff
there's a huge movement of people who
are turned off
by a lot of the just swampiness of the
establishment in general the problem is
that
the other side always scares them back
into their base right so a lot of the
kind of like liberal left
who doesn't like the woke stuff and
there's a lot of them out there
i think the vast majority of them are
silent because they're kind of cowards
about it
um which i think is part of the
personality type of the liberal left in
general
but that so they're too cowardice to
ever be called racist
but then they see trump and they're like
okay well i this guy's too gross for me
so i'm just going to stick in this kind
of camp here
or some of them yeah well that's true
i'm going to vote
that is true too but the truth is that
you have to find different ways to
attack this stuff
and and what doesn't get confronted
enough to me
about the the whole woke movement is
that like
like people battle it and how stupid it
is and and that's kind of easy
and and it's true and it's ju it's
divisive and it's racist and it's
horrible and it's also just really
really dumb
like it's really really dumb you can
this is why ben shapiro got so popular
because he'd
battle their woke ideas and and people
just looking and be like this is so
like absurdly ridiculous he can just
shred these ideas up
but what's not mentioned enough is what
is actually going on here
and how brilliant the whole woke
movement was
it's like why do you think this stuff is
pushed
by government and big corporations and
big banks at the highest level
like why is it it's like well what was
the left doing
10 years ago you know say whatever you
will about the left
10 years ago the left was standing
outside the big banks
screaming we are the 99 percent
you think that got some attention out of
people do you think it's crazy that all
of a sudden
they have completely thrown you off the
scent now
and just have you focusing on
microaggressions just imagine
like i i was saying this uh to when i
was on a rogan a couple weeks ago to him
where i was like imagine you're
uh goldman sachs exec right and you have
bernie sanders coming up and he's going
there should be no billionaires
and you're like huh and then some other
like woke kid comes up and goes i want
to talk about microaggressions
i think you'd be like yeah i have a
microaggressions guy has something he
wants to say let's let's focus on that
guy that's
so this has all been just to pull the
wall over the
the eyes of the left because the left
when it's at its best
is actually a threat to this power
structure yeah
i want to show you guys this comic
because uh it's great
and i've mentioned it before it's a man
sitting at a desk
outside his window it's a business guy
sitting at his food desk with his things
you know his degrees on the wall and
outside is a bunch of people protesting
holding a big sign occupy wall street
stop corporate greed fat cats
and the man inside is smirking on the
phone and he says introduce them to
identity politics
and i remember because i was at occupy
wall street as was luke when this
started happening
when it went from we are the 99 percent
the big banks have extracted the wealth
of the people for too long
to all of a sudden twinkle fingers
progressive stack if you're white you're
not allowed to speak
yeah and when we look at all of their
kind of woke ideology it's meant to
divide and conquer whether it's your
family members whether
it's your race whether it's your sex
whether it's your identity
whatever little category they could put
you in to make you feel
different and make you fight someone
else who is not on your side
intersectional identifying as it or this
or whatever you want to do
you're creating essentially packs that
are meant to
drive wedges into our modern day culture
so we're at each other's throats
and being afraid to talk to each other
because you don't want to offend someone
if you use the proper pronouns or
what kind of civilization in society are
we living in where we can't even say hey
you buddy bloke whatever there's a guy
in the uk who went to jail for calling
someone a bloke
and this is why this is why the left
eats itself
it is not a bug it is a feature of what
they do
they don't want them to ever actually be
able to unify around anything cohesive
so everything they do is offensive my my
favorite moment
in this whole nonsense was when one
organization came out
it was like international organization
for women or something some i forgot
what's called who the name was
and they said whimxen w-o-m-x-n
wemmickson that's i don't know and they
say it's pronounced women's
and they got attacked by the left and
they said
that using the word wmixon is offensive
because you are implying you need a
special word for trans women but trans
women are women
how dare you say this so then they
apologized and put it back to women and
they still got flack
because women is an old patriarchal term
that separates
the the the the genders that don't exist
and the the point is
they've created an ideology that is
attacking itself on purpose
so that it can't unify against it
we used to talk about uh facts we used
to talk about evidence
now we're talking about what are you
what's your identity and i get attacked
on this non-stop on twitter you're a
misogynist you're
i mean i'm like well you are right i
choose not to even engage in that
because i'm like
let's talk about the merits of this
debate and people don't
they want to guess but it's it's it's
look they've turned
the best aspect of the left against
the left and made it a vice rather than
a virtue
in the same sense that look what they
did with the the terror wars
was they turned the right-wing impulse
to be tough and protect your country and
defend the bill of rights this really
beautiful noble thing
and they turned that into slaughtering
poor people in third world countries
they take this noble thing and they make
it evil they're geniuses and what
they've done is they take this leftist
kind of impulse to care about the
marginalized which in its purest form
is a good thing something that's a
society a moral society needs
and they've turned this into attacking
everyone for
every stupid reason but it's it's to
luke's point this is the perfect like
it's the perfect divide and conquer
tactic that can never
you can make sure that they never focus
on the fact that
we have more in common with each other
than we ever will
with donald trump or joe when they're
fighting each other the corporations
do whatever they want and what i've said
before is that
when we had these civil rights groups
that were fighting against racism
fighting for
for social justice civil rights it was
kind of like
an immune immune response we had
something bad
and we said it's not we're not going to
succeed if we're divided all the time
and so this movement emerged for
equality under the law in the 1964 civil
rights act followed by loving v virginia
which said
under the law we are all americans and
we and that is our identity american
citizens
then we we start to get an immune
overreaction
now these people are looking for racism
everywhere they still are operating
under this risk like immune response but
it's more now like an autoimmune
disorder
attacking healthy cells thinking it's a
diseased cell
and that's when a living creature dies
there are numerous disorders
that are like that an over-active
targeting the wrong thing and destroying
it
okay so just really quickly it's a very
quick story but uh
my buddy uh scott horton who i don't
know if you know him he's a genius he's
the managing editor at
antiwar.com he's the greatest anyway you
guys check out scott horton if you don't
know who he is
um but he was telling me this story and
there's a great example of like
how they they divide us with this stuff
when we should all be together
but it was at the bundy ranch standoff
and he was talking to one of these i
forget but it was one of the like
leaders in the black lives matter
movement at the time and he was
basically telling this lady he was like
you guys should stand with the bundy
ranchers
because you guys have so much in common
here and you could unify
and make it like a left and right thing
and really focus on who the enemy is
and uh she showed him a picture and it
was one of the
bundy ranchers had a f um blm
shirt on and he goes no c they hate us
they hate everything we stand for and he
goes no no no
that's bureau of land management
aka the cops they hate the cops
right like they're the same as you it's
literally just a different
version of the same thing trying to
explain the bundy thing to people is
funny because it
comes up all the time i'm like yeah they
were they were criticizing blm and
they're like black lives matter and i'm
not a bureau of land management they're
like
oh yeah other in other words the federal
cops like it's
it's the same thing it's just literally
people who are
saying that they want to live their
lives and there are these federal agents
who are coming through and
bringing violence to them for no
justifiable reason
and that is something that could unite
people but you got to me the way it to
attack
the the woke stuff is more than just
calling it stupid and smashing it
because that's just been done to death
at this point
is to let good decent leftists know that
they have fooled you with this
and they have and they are laughing at
you those same bankers
are cracking up laughing that you're
talking about
white supremacy rather than talking
about
banker bailouts which is a much more
real thing
we went from occupy wall street we are
the 99 percent
angry over the bailouts for the big
banks that ripped us off screwed us
destroyed the retirement accounts
and in the first week of occupy there
was unity there were older conservatives
there there were libertarians there
people like luke ron paul libertarian
types were down there saying we agree
the establishment the big banks etc
once it turned woke we are now 10 years
on almost 10 years
and what do we get the i guess basically
as you mentioned
there we're now witnessing the largest
transfer of wealth in human history
and the left is in favor of it well
right because and but what is the left
gotten so
you get the largest transfer of wealth
in human history so much of it going to
these big bankers
but they will send their white execs to
diversity training there you go so
that's what you got out of all
they brought you off for the cheapest
job the military-industrial accomplice
comp uh the military-industrial complex
is now run by women that's right oh yeah
bravo everybody ladies
you are the new war mongers women can do
it too yes the bombs that are going to
be dropping on yemen are going to be
dropped by the orders of a woman so
everything is saved everything is great
and manufactured by the women
exactly ordered by the u.s federal
government and potentially it's female
vice president
and well you brought up something that
i've been talking about and i think
we've been talking about for a number of
years now we've seen the writing on the
wall we've seen it slowly
incrementalized and we have to
understand also these people are very
patient
they know they see threats and one of
the biggest threats against them is
people coming together realizing that
they have a lot more in common than they
have different and working together
towards
helping themselves benefiting themselves
but also not becoming victims to
the machine the system the multinational
corporations the government whoever it
may be
i think it's obviously a fact that
people are getting screwed over more
than ever you can't deny that
how best can you keep them in a way
where they're they don't notice it
keep them in a con a constant state of
fear
of fighting of of not knowing what's
going to happen tomorrow and i think
this is the stage that we're at right
now
yeah no i agree with that and i also
think that this
uh great suppression on social media
is something that they've been very
patient about and has been in the works
for a while because this has been the
[ __ ] in the armor
for quite a while like if you were to
look at the establishment
uh another [ __ ] great economist
it's like i could do the first half hour
pretty good but after that it's really
hard
uh but this great economist bob murphy
made this a hilarious video
years back this is like must have been
like 2013 and he was uh
like mocking being the advisor to the
ruling elite
like if he was going to come in and
basically give them like you know like
a report of what his his advice to them
to do is and he
you know and he's like okay uh ruling
elite by the way doing a great job
uh you know control the currency you
control public education you control the
corporate press
you control the military you can bomb
whoever you want to you guys really just
doing an unbelievable job but you got
this problem and it's the internet
and like there's this really big issue
here and it's not just that somebody can
say on social media
hey i think hillary clinton is
completely full of it but then people
can also look at it and go huh that got
10
000 likes yeah oh wow there's 10 000
more people who agree just with me
and just with this guy and this has been
the biggest achilles heel
for the ruling elite and so of course
they have to try to plug this up
so for all the negative stuff that we
were saying before about social media
which is all very real
um it is also kind of our only hope
right it's kind of our only hope that
some of these ideas can spread without
the gatekeepers
you know what man there was a a meme or
a video put out by a left-wing
personality of people setting up a
guillotine in front of uh it was like in
uh
what was it guatemala what's mexico yeah
it was mexico
yeah yeah they set up a guillotine
guilty whenever you pronounce it in
front of a
a government building and they were like
you know hey
they're right you could we could be
doing this together and i'm kind of like
well
i'm not a fan of the robespierre style
just randomly pulling people out of
government buildings or anything like
that
and i think we need trials because
trials make make a statement to the
people about what we tolerate
but yeah the left and the right don't
like what what the establishment is
doing
and the right and left absolute
absolutely could at least agree on that
much and say
how about we all vote for one thing you
know it's interesting that we saw uh you
know brett weinstein's unity party
get censored because they don't like
that over target
they don't like exactly they don't like
that stuff i mean look there has to be
together there are some issues right
that you just
you couldn't imagine would not get
overwhelming support
and like like just to take one really
easy one
and corporate welfare yeah i mean you
cannot
tell me that no more corporate welfare
every freaking
billionaire in this country is on
welfare so don't give me arguments
don't give me arguments about socialism
verse capitalism this is the absolute
worst of both
that no one supports i gotta i gotta
give a shout out to shoehornhead because
she tweeted
uh she said uh rydos this is what bezos
took from you and it was parlor shut
down
and she was like uh how about we get
revenge by redistributing his wealth
i thought it was hilarious because i'm
like i'm sure a lot of conservatives are
going to be like do it
yeah no that's right but at the very
least even if you're not advocating
going and taking what they have how
about don't take from the middle class
taxpayers and give to them
i mean can we at least like you can't
tell me that wouldn't get 90 plus
percent approval
but no one is with there's no political
will to do it the bailouts the big banks
from all these different companies but
really the omnibus bill
was kind of like it was no longer that
people were being pissed on and being
told it was raining
they were now looking up and seeing who
was doing it
and i'm like left and right you guys can
hug on this one right yeah and be like
look you can argue about whether or not
someone's the right identity or whether
they hold the right beliefs
but can we all agree right now they're
peeing on us and we should stop them
from doing it
yeah then afterwards we'll get we'll
take a shower we'll get some new clothes
then we'll go back to arguing but for
the time being you can see what's going
on right can you i i said on my show
um and it was like you know a couple
weeks before the capitol hill
the capitol building thing but i said it
felt like
they were daring the american people to
revolt
like it felt like after after nine
months of locking people in their home
destroying businesses and they're
sitting here going
hmm we'll give you 600. all right i mean
i guess we could consider giving you a
little bit more than that
oh by the way israel's up to 3 billion
this year and you're almost like are you
like are you actually like daring people
because you are pushing people to a
direction where
understandably they're going to lose it
but they don't care you know why
because they know that an individual
will react emotionally without strategy
that will benefit them yeah in the end
storming the capital gave them
everything
yeah everything trump said peacefully
cheer on politicians because trump i
genuinely believe thought
that they were going to go and and he
was going to get his you know complaints
heard i think well what do you even
think his
like did you listen uh he's a doctor
well i'm sure you uh listened to
the the phone call that got put out that
he had with
the secretary of state of georgia and it
was one of the things to me and i've
basically been saying for a while you
know this thing that i said earlier that
trump isn't what the left projects on to
him he isn't what the right projects
onto him he just is what he is he's what
we always knew
he was he's trump but even for me going
in like that
i was so blown away how much he was just
trump on the phone call right there was
no direction even
there was no plan there wasn't like okay
listen we need to focus on these three
counties and if we do this we can take
it to this court and then i can get this
overturned and then
he's literally just goes on like a rant
for 15 minutes at the beginning and he
goes
you know we have the biggest crowds i
know and um all the polls said we were
gonna lose big
and they were all wrong and i think we
did tremendously well
and you're like oh my god even behind
closed doors of course he's just the
exact same guy he has
no other gear there's no so i don't
really know that there
i think the plan was in trump's mind
he's like
i'm tremendous biden's a loser there's
no way he won
this whole thing's rigged i'm gonna keep
calling it stupid
until i'm president again and there was
really no more specific plan than that
it was
just like i'll like he always does i'll
tremendous and insult my way into a
second term
i don't i don't know if he was actually
thinking about where it was going
i think he was just expressing himself
complaining and telling his supporters
over and over again how he felt
yeah and then what did he really say
we're gonna march peacefully and cheer
for some politicians
but people had already been storming the
capital so what ends up happening then
is
these people made a serious tactical
error thinking that you could use
violence
we are you know i had a lot of people in
the comments say oh but tim look at
these historical moments and i'm like
bro they didn't have twitter back then
they didn't have youtube they didn't
have social media there you you really
have to think about this okay
um you go back man this is crazy to
think about
watching pirates of the caribbean right
he comes up on that in the first the
first movie the boat's sinking and he
jumps in the dock
he walks up and the guy says what's your
name he goes uh smith
and the guy and then he gives the guy
money and i'm like why did he pay him
they don't have ids
he could have literally just said smith
and carried on but like
we're we're in this day and age where we
assume identity is like
you know it's always proven because you
always carry the id that you have to
bribe someone
no you literally just lie and they could
not prove it they'd take your word for
it and there was just more trust i
suppose
but also think about what life was like
back you ever play red dead redemption
or
redhead redemption 2 i mean there's like
in the wild west
if you were in the middle of the desert
you saw a dude and you just killed him
and took his stuff
no one would ever find out we're in the
information age everybody knows exactly
what's
happening and people don't tolerate
those kinds of things they didn't then
they don't now and now everyone can know
about it which means
you win by having the moral high ground
and proving you are just and correct and
right
and outwitting your political rivals
yeah not by running in
yelling and banging on glass and then
they point at you and say they're the
problem and this proves it you made a
very good point talking about how it was
almost as if the establishment was
asking for
trouble with with that 600 debate that
was maybe two thousand dollars but we
also have to understand this is on the
backdrop of
a lot of these politicians saying you
must be locked down you must stay inside
your business must close you must lose
your life
and how you lived it normally before as
i go out to a restaurant and spend
thousands of dollars
indoor dining i'm gonna get my hair cut
i'm gonna do what i want
as of course people were just left
losing everything in front of them
and we still haven't dealt with the
significant financial ramification that
it's still not here
we're in that huge larger it's going to
be gone for years dude i was just uh i
was driving around the other day
um in the upper west side of new york
city where i
used to live for years um and i was like
heartbreaking i mean like i i was like
getting choked up driving where one out
of every four
stores that i used to go to and like i
know these people i knew their families
a bunch of family businesses
they're gone this is like where the
first home that i brought my daughter
back to from the hospital and the little
like bodega we used to go to in this
restaurant and this these are these are
real people's lives who have been
destroyed and then these people who
would who would attack you
they'd attack anybody if they were out
in the street you remember that the
what was it on msnbc or cnn when they're
like look this guy's not wearing a mask
and he goes your cameraman's not wearing
them right
right you know and then had the video
had the cell phone video to prove it and
then
they're oh my god there's kids on the
beaches probably by the way the safest
place you could possibly be
on the beach and then all of a sudden
there's riots and you're told no that's
okay yeah yeah or a politician going out
to dinner that's okay
so yeah by the end of the year i
understand where people are like
ready to to lose their minds how could
you not understand well
to we gotta go super chats well just
really quick according to the science it
was black lives matter that stopped the
spread of covet so that was the
university of colorado i believe boulder
so we just need a little bit more riots
they said i forgot their logic was but
that the protest for black lives matter
resulted in more people being indoors
which slowed the spread which makes no
sense because they were all outdoors
but let's think they would be
celebrating the capital attack let's do
it
let's jump to super chats if you haven't
already smash
the like button and also we are in the
process
of smoothing out timcast.com so check
out timcast.com
become a member and we're going to start
producing members only content very soon
some people were emailing about issues
with logging in we're getting it all
sorted so
uh you can donate now at timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have
exclusive interviews we're gonna have
private events
first come first serve tickets will go
out to people and uh that's you get when
you sign up so you can support the show
by doing it
and uh let's take your super chats again
smash the like button subscribe
notification bell
we got red dragon he says oh this is
what i actually mentioned early says
trump is the best president of our
lifetimes
and should be tried for war crimes both
unironically true
and we talked a great deal about that
and uh i i
mean good point scott hale says wish i
could travel through timelines
where the trump where trump wins the
election and see how the left reacts and
the news justifies it
just how drastically it would be
different i mean i definitely think so
uh the stuff we're hearing from like
project veritas
of what these people were saying about
if trump wins
it was going to be worse than what we're
seeing now no question
let's see mick mchatton talking about
bitcoin so much
if you have no internet you have no
money bitcoin is shadow steel make
people change money then shut down
access
look how easy att bomb took out major
region
except bitcoin can be put in cold
storage and transferred offline
there there there are ways to do it
let's see
and and and for that matter it's like
you could burn money like you could
destroy physical paper so there's
look someone could hack your account
there's a lot of security issues
everything fdr just came and rounded up
people's gold i mean the government can
do a lot of stuff if they want to
yep trent lamolino says dave is the
reason why i joined the libertarian
party
dave hit them with the skank hit them
with the skank's hands
p-o-t-p the libertarian party man i love
that meme libertarian ideals versus
libertarian candidates you know what i'm
talking about yeah of course
yeah but i'll tell you man uh that's
that's beginning to change there's this
uh the the mises caucus in the
libertarian party it's like
it's an insurrection not an insurrection
an insurgency i'll say within the
libertarian party
that's really making it the home of like
the ron paul revolution
and i'm i'm a big part of that and
that's like i i highly recommend people
check
that out borders are against borders the
well the the basic libertarian position
is that um that border should be private
essentially i mean that's like
the true anarcho-capitalist position uh
i don't know if the mises caucus has
like a plank on borders
but what they focus on is like hardcore
ron paul
issues and the lockdowns and the wars
and corporate bailouts all that like
really good libertarian stuff highly
recommend people go check out the mises
caucus in the libertarian party
drew jones says so glad you got dave on
i'm very grateful to have someone like
him carrying the cultural torch for
libertarianism
he should be a regular with luke oh yeah
you know whatever
come on down what is what is skank
nation
oh it's uh my my comedy podcast is
called legion of skanks
legion of skanks with uh louis jay gomez
and big j okay
two funniest people on the planet
political pothead says what's good dave
i live in staten island and just
switched my party affiliation to
libertarian i voted for larry sharpe
since new york needs school choice
mcconnell doesn't understand his base
trump's approval is up since capital in
some polls in some polls it's
way down depending on which one you look
at which polls do you trust rasmussen
has him up
and you know politico has him way down
yeah who knows
yeah are you familiar with larry sharpe
yeah larry sharp ran for uh for governor
in new york's great guy
and uh you know it was it's a pretty
tough uphill battle to run as a
libertarian in new york but he called
that cuomo it was pretty beautiful
mr beard says wyoming here congrats to
liz cheney on her last term she is out
in two years
i wouldn't be surprised shalom
uh i don't know out mesquin says
gop is dead time for a new party or make
libertarian a real party
i mean maybe that's the the path the
problem is you know we had
um who was the the woman i can't believe
i'm forgetting her name
no i i can joe jordan joe jorgensen
no disrespect but she came out with that
statement about anti-racism
and i was like oh did that stick out to
you did that one bother you yeah no well
no
no no i know i'm arguing with
libertarians about this when a
libertarian says
you must do something i go whoa
well and then wait a minute look it was
that was a really stupid
uh blunder that by the way i don't think
was put out by her i think was put out
by whoever is managing your twitter but
there's no excuse for that when you're
running a presidential campaign
uh yeah that was a big mistake and
that's that doesn't the libertarian
party oppose civil rights law like you
were saying
make discrimination legal well i think
the the libertarian party or i don't
know what the
libertarians would oppose one aspect of
the civil rights bill
of 1964 which is that the forced
integration of private businesses and
and the woke left agrees it actually
worked really well with what joe jorge
was
saying because in california they tried
pulling that out of their constitution
the non-discrimination laws they
absolutely want to discriminate
they they agree for totally different
reasons yes yeah you know so it's like i
guess maybe that worked yeah
it was there there were a lot of
problems in the in the presidential
campaign joe jorgensen is like a good
person
she just doesn't she didn't she didn't
run a good campaign didn't she want alan
dershowitz to be on the supreme court
yeah she put that out and then
apologized for it right afterwards
it was look man like what the the
campaign was just a mess and yeah she
put out a list of supreme court nominees
and he was one of them and then
everyone's like what are you doing
and then she was like uh no actually we
take him off of it or something
it was just ridiculous i had when i when
i was voting in jersey they had a thing
on the back where it was like right in
for like school board or whatever and i
wrote in ron and rand paul
cause i'm like there you go i'm not
gonna write in and like i'm not gonna
vote for someone i don't know are
writing a name
and so i'm like the only people i would
actually trust not to make things worse
or the people who typically vote no on
things
that's the interesting thing about ron
paul that i always really liked is that
i disagree with him a lot on
you know certain social and cultural
issues but he was kind of like i'm not
going to vote for empowering the
government i'm like okay so then you're
not going to get in my way
you know what i mean like you're not
going to impose on me so why should i
care about what you personally believe
which is which is really the way it
should be and and the truth is that even
if you're
if you're a very culturally conservative
person
um all you have to do is look at what
the government has done to this culture
they've completely destroyed it and so
the look there's nothing more
destructive
to uh community to cultural bonds to the
tradition of
family and religion than big government
and this is how it always works
daniel maxwell says i do not think
impeachment of president trump is going
to have the effect they think it will
have
it could instead blow up in their faces
in the worst part in the worst way
possible which is not good for anybody
but might be better than the alternative
also i
think they need to i think it's a bad
idea it's it's fruitless it's pointless
they're not going to convict them in in
time if if they're worried
you know i see this meme where they're
like i rented out my pool house to a
bunch of my friend
to my friend and a bunch of his friends
trashed the place their lease is up in
20 days should i
or you know in two weeks should i let
him stay or kick him out now and
everyone's like duh trump should be
impeached no
yes the eviction process takes 30 days
even in the real world the analogy makes
no sense
you can't evict someone right now you
have to give them a notice
and then you go through a court
proceeding and then you know what
happens when you try to evict them they
can actually stay longer
people don't get this they could
challenge it and ask for continuation
and the judge might say sure
so if they're up and sit in 14 days
maybe just sit back and say well it'll
be gone soon
they're planning on leaving they're not
happy about it they're gonna trash the
place i get it
but the alternative could be worse they
don't they don't they don't there also
seems to be
no interest do you remember when uh
jordan peterson was on bill maher
and he kind of like stumped the whole
left-wing panel when he was just like
so what's the plan you guys want to get
trump at what's the plan for the tens of
millions of people who voted for him
like how do you bring them back in the
society and they're all like um
well and it seems like there's really no
plan like no one's concerned about the
fact that
74 million people just voted for this
guy
and you want to now like undo the will
of the last 63 million people who voted
for him
and it seems like they have no interest
in trying to bring those people back in
the field they want to squash them
rita ho says shout out to luke for
bringing up taiwan we have been on our
own all my life and will continue to
fight
by the way will biden challenge 2a and
should we expect civil war from this if
he
if he does so yeah i mean that's one of
the
big clash points well look he's pl he
wants to ban online sales of firearms
accessories and ammo
he's now got the senate and the house
and they are going to pass
sweeping gun control legislation it is
going to get
bad yeah for all of us who have been
saying for a while and i'm guilty of
this who are like
uh you know look they'll never come
after the guns because that'll be a
civil war and they would never overreach
that much you're like
i don't know i mean they locked
everybody in their house all year and no
one
really did anything about it so maybe
they well trump went after the guns and
banned
bump stocks he pretty much made a
population of the united states
felons overnight with just a decree
going further than the atf ever even
wished to go
yeah occupy says tim dave the problem
wasn't simply that trump didn't
understand
it's true he isn't primarily
intellectual it's that he doesn't have
the connections
he isn't a connected cool political
insider they hate him
classism no but you know what that's
that's still kind of a cop-out
donald trump put douglas mcgregor
in as the top advisor at the defense
department
after the election that this was the
guy to put in to end the wars this is
like the
guy if you don't know him go go look
into him he is the military
genius guy who wants to end all of these
wars
trump knew who to put in he just decided
to put him in at the end
he didn't bring him in at the beginning
he brought bolton in before he brought
that guy in
do you know that uh the american
conservative wrote an article i think it
was
who does it is that who's the guy who
does that the american conservative i'm
not sure it's been a while since i read
the article
he said fire bolton hire tulsi gabbard
oh yeah there you go
she's gonna stop this stuff and trump
trump had people around him he had brad
parscale telling him
to get on parlor in early 2020 and trump
didn't do it you know why
he listened to kushner yeah i roll
yikes too bad they would have been huge
and i've been saying the whole time all
trump has to do is join any other social
platform and they won't be able to ban
it
because it would be too big it would be
too much but trump
didn't do it they were so the republican
party
donald trump and all of these people
just did not understand what was
happening in this country it is
mind-boggling 88 million people would
have followed
yeah it would have changed the landscape
and rebalance things it could
that one move of trump being like from
now on i'm gonna be posting on minds.com
boom change the landscape of social
media create real competition
and simmer tensions down between
everybody the media would be forced to
report on what's happening on other
platforms
instead trump finally waits till the
very last minute gets nuked and then
can't do anything about it because then
they go after parlor before he's a
chance to even sign up yep
jeez matthew
jock says bottom gun coffee company
wants to send you guys some free organic
coffee
keep up the excellent content and let us
know if you're looking for some sponsors
uh always we have a couple right now
that would be great
do we do what what's the email we have
that people can send stuff to
we have spin the ufo that's gmail spin
the ufo at gmail.com and we'll we're
going to create it
we're going to create some new emails so
but uh send us that info and then we'd
love to take a look at uh coffee
companies that'd be fun
brandon icock says hey dave somebody i
used to look up to supports the
the lp but disagrees with monetary
policies they support
said the fed serves a purpose and voted
for mccain as a conservative
would this put him in the loser brigade
well i don't know
about the loser brigade but i mean
voting for mccain and supporting the fed
are two just damn near unforgivable
things to do but
no look i mean the the federal reserve
is basically
the center of this whole banking cartel
so if you really want to take on this
system that is extra that is
extrapolating
all of this wealth uh or what's the word
i'm looking for not extrapolating that
is
extreme
people and giving it to this this cartel
this is literally it's it's the
lifeblood of the warfare state of the
welfare state so that's the center of it
and and has to be opposed strong
armed robbery i think they call this
yeah there you go that works
awesome human says been lurking the q
sites to see what it's all about they're
seriously gaslighting people and
creating fervor
y'all see that alex jones video where he
finally snaps and he's like
you're lying ah
yeah good for him but who did he snap on
he snapped he was talking to some people
yeah something about i saw tim dillon uh
tweet it he goes
imagine uh where you are at life when
alex jones is yelling at you to calm
down
for real it's crazy uh i i so
you know for a long time i didn't know a
whole lot about it but since it's become
more
recognizable and more prominent
especially with the capital stuff i was
reading that they
they claimed mueller was secretly
working for trump the whole time
and that it was a plot to arrest hillary
clinton or something yeah and i'm like
why would you believe that
they talked about bombing iran being a
good thing and i'm like are you kidding
me
it's just it was just a whole lot of
nonsense though and i've seen people
share with me i've seen people who are
left
share cue stuff and i'm just like they
don't realize
they don't know what it is no no joke
like
i guess the you've got these crazy
conspiracies who are we talking about
with this the were you just saying
earlier the left and the right
oh no it was a super chat the other day
where they said there are people who
think that trump is dog whistling
secrets to them about supporting him for
his attempt to keep the election
while the left secretly thinks that he's
he's dog whistling to his russian
masters that he's actually a spy
both of these groups have lost it yeah
like it's not it's not happening
and the truth is he's just bragging
about his crowd sizes right right there
there were so many people there they
loved me the radical left came it was
how them
i think it's crazy that donald trump
does that thing where he like he does
the the pinched fingers
and from that you got people doing the
okay sign and so at some point
you had i think it was stephen miller
straightening his shirt and they were
like look he's doing a double white
power sign it's like
you know my problem is that the social
media will ban all the q people
and claim it's because you know we don't
allow the conspiracy stuff but the left
is going nuts with the exact same
garbage yeah and the other problem is
that there are
real conspiracies and then anybody who
wants to talk about them in a serious
manner
ends up being labeled with all of this
other stuff i mean there there are like
i mean look getting us into the war in
iraq was a conspiracy this was really a
small cabal of people who lied us into a
war but then anytime you use the term
conspiracy theory
now everybody's thinking about these
genuinely paranoid schizophrenic people
who believe this crazy stuff
you know what man and so when i started
seeing
people i've known for a long time
posting unhinged q-level garbage because
they hate trump so much they'll believe
anything that comes out of you know
someone's
social media account i was like man
now i like dude i know i know some
people who went full flat earth and i'm
like how
how do you believe the earth is flat
dude
and they do and i know people who
believe that trump really was a russian
spy and like
you don't understand and i'm like what
happened to you man
donald trump is the guy from the tv who
talked about firing people he's he he
wasn't working for russia when he was on
the apprentice bro
yeah what happened and i see all that
and i'm like man now i totally
understand why they're like we want to
ban all of these people and shut it all
down the only problem is they don't ban
the left
well the reality is i'm not in favor of
any of it let the people say the crazy
so that we can ridicule it and mock it
and explain to people why it's wrong
when you when they ban these people they
push them into these corners where they
can only
regurgitate the same thing and the whole
thing and the whole thing that's so
ridiculous is that these are the same
people who who preach about democracy
and so you're like okay well listen if
the good ideas can't win out in a free
discussion
then how do you expect people have the
power to vote for the leaders who are
going to determine the policy of what
is allowed to be said like this is also
either people are capable of doing this
in a society in an open society
or we're not and it doesn't work and in
that case you should just support like a
dictatorship or something like that but
obviously we all know the problems
associated with that so let's let all
the ideas be expressed and let the good
ones win out i saw a tweet and they they
said i can't remember who it was
they said at some point will the left
reflect on the fact that
if you have to suppress people's
conversations and ideas
in order to maintain you know your
ideology there's something deeply flawed
with your
ideology no they won't they'll just they
believe in subjective subjective
morality
and they don't think you know they
believe truth there's no truth but power
and things like that so they'll just do
what they want to be
in power don uh denying s
says ben shapiro made this point but as
a gen x i can attest
that there has been growing hatred for
the right for decades republican
politicians don't fight back
when trump ran for president people
finally saw someone who will hit back
yep that's for sure all right let's see
we got here
it was a weak punch chris brown says for
having dave smith on the show
the libertarian philosophy and nap is
the only hope for a better future
it's very likely the greatest
accomplishment in human history it is a
philosophy that is underrated by
everyone
i agree in many ways and i wish we had
more people who adhered to it
the challenge i see is a lot of
countries don't like china's never going
to agree or they'll tell you they do
like oh yeah you're right non-aggression
principle that's great they'll go behind
your back and
you know undermine your economy well
look i mean
the the non-aggression principle is a
principle it's a moral principle that
says it's it's immoral to initiate
violence against peaceful people
that's not to say that everybody's going
to abide by it but truthfully speaking
a huge part of the rise of china and the
fall of the united states of america
is that while we're waging war after
stupid war after stupid war they're
going around and investing in places
and this is why we're we have an
expanding empire that is destroying our
country
and they have been much more stealthy in
this now their human rights violations
are
you know abhorrent and and awful um and
i think there's a strong argument that
we shouldn't work with the chinese
government in any capacity
that that can help them um you know i
really like jimmy dore
because i feel like he's one of the very
few legitimate
like speak telling the truth about how
he feels and what he wants very lefty
totally for medicare for all but he
calls out the wars the corporations the
crony politicians
and then i look at a lot of these
progressive personalities and they just
told the establishment line
but they add in medicare for all yeah we
agree they'll be like we like bernie
go joe biden woohoo yeah now the thing
that i love about jimmy dore and i i
definitely disagree with him
particularly on some economic stuff
but the thing that just makes me want to
salute him like
is that jimmy dore's like he'll if he
supports someone
because they're like against the wars
and then they go ah well i mean i guess
i kind of
think we should fight this war he will
just rail them the next day
like he is about his principles and not
just he doesn't fall into
any of the like the tricks he's he's
that dude's really
str strong to what he believes yeah
somebody mentioned pelosi is missing
from congress have you heard that no i'm
not sure i remember seeing a hashtag
somebody said it had been two days since
she's been there i mean is that is that
a
big deal yeah i don't even know if
that's normal or not how long does she
usually they often have performance
sessions and then just disappear
he's probably just getting a haircut
yeah no doubt yeah she's at the salon
she's out partying i mean maybe their
big victory
gareth green says do you know anything
about the housing crisis in california
policies to protect property values and
so forth are quite rampant
it's classist if not racist i actually
don't i know they have a serious
homelessness problem
is insane all right let's see kyle
cameron says you guys are so wrong it
hurts the republicans come back is 2024.
someone also said though that trump is
center-left and that if they can't run
him
then they're doomed trump is moderate
that that's you know even i mentioned
this vox.com wrote an article calling
the moderate back in i think 2016.
yeah there there wasn't really too much
that was super
radical about trump's uh policies that
he proposed
especially compared to other presidents
i think it was more like his personality
and stuff like that but yet he was kind
of like an 80s democrat
i mean like yeah i'm kind of skeptical
about wars i want to control
immigration because it drives down wages
i'm not really into these free trade
deals
i mean that could that could have been
an 80s democrat yep let's see
uh max mulvahill says thanks for having
on michael malus's better half
let's see ryan says buzzfeed news is
reporting capital meemaw
was not taken at the dc riot but a
picture taken in topeka kansas
yes i heard that correction ah
we had that photo of that little old
granny waving a little flag and
everybody thought it was at the capitol
and that's my bad i should have looked
into it i just made that assumption
because you know
i wasn't paying attention doing a better
job i was sad to lose that one
super cute i mean it's still a good
picture what was she if she was
protesting in topeka yeah yes
all right let's see nelson correct uh
cara janis says are you guys familiar
with fukults boomerang
what are your thoughts on the idea also
i feel historically we are closer to the
reformation era
with the internet being the new printing
press are you familiar with that uh for
cults
i think i've heard of it before but i
don't know not familiar yeah i'm not
a path of resilience just said spot on
tim i don't know to which you are
agreeing with
but uh everything fantastic i love him
mike uh mr hunt first name mike
says didn't come here to watch didn't
come by to read comments
i just read the title and and will
express what we all know powder keg
no one is considering the real horror of
all of this while they the left do
terrible things
you know let's see then uh the
nickerman says thanks tim fool
amen and a woman brother all right
all right let's keep going fall
khan says trump needs to start a maga
party let the republicans figure out
where to get votes when we all leave and
that's all that's left are establishment
voters
yeah they'll get like 10 of what they
got before
i think trump's the one man right like
the right now the person who can break
the two-party system
i really do think so yeah but the the
issue is that
donald trump has now been silenced on
social media
donald trump is 75
and fat and i'm just saying that's
it's just that's not the best position
to be in
now to start something i'm not like just
saying it to insult
him i'm just saying he doesn't have
twitter anymore he doesn't have a tv
show anymore
so he's got to figure out now if he's
going to be the guy to lead some big
movement going forward
how he gets his voice out there no he
makes the endorsement and his son runs
it or his sons run it
and then they encourage all supporters
say if you support you know
donald trump and everything he stood for
then we're going to be pressing a new
party because the gop
did not have our backs yeah and we're
going to send a message and i'll tell
you this there are a lot of people
what i've been basically hearing is
people saying if you have already lost
to the democrats and expect to lose
again
vote for a new party because the
republicans don't deserve your support
yeah i've heard a lot of people saying
that too i just i i gotta say
i i think that we're gonna see the trump
family get crushed
i think they can't let them they they
just can't let these guys maintain this
because this is the only group that
really poses the immediate threat to
them right now
and i think we're going to see them all
silenced on social media and i i really
wouldn't be surprised if they try to
bring criminal charges
i mean people are looking at sedition
and conspiracy charges for being at the
capitol facing at least 20 years that's
going to send a very big chilling effect
to a lot of people
yeah sure well stefan luna says joe
jorgensen
made gary johnson look like murray
rothbard
that's saying a lot that's uh that's a
big statement there
i don't know quite if i 100 agree with
that
brittany hart says larry sharp 202 or
2024 i voted for him in 2018
he he got he's got the the best
uh liberian ideas no it's as liberian
well he is i've always said liberty
sharp is a solid librarian
[Laughter]
oh what what a poor country uh denny
decibel says hey tim
have you reached out to david barton yet
and invited him onto your show
i'm not familiar david barton
um nicole petnick says we need to play
the same game as the establishment
tell all the leftists that it's the
banksters in federal reserve that are
the true racists and super racists and
supremacists
and how much richer we'd all be without
them i mean that's that's true though
yeah if you want to talk about wealth
redistribution maybe it's time we just
say you know what leftists
we agree the fed is ripping everybody
off you want to talk about wealth
redistribution and universal healthcare
here we go then you'll see how fast your
show gets banned from the internet
it's today you know on today's episode
we're going to start with what we
normally say everybody should unite
around the federal reserve and then
all right let's see what we got spaceman
says read the demon in democracy
by rizzard lagutco great podcast thank
you
let's see karn is that a cam
karna handen says who does dave learn
all his foreign policy knowledge from
um well i mean i sh i i'd give a shout
out to antiwar.com
uh they're fantastic the libertarian
institute uh the
libertarianinstitute.org antiwar.com
um i mean i learned a ton of it from ron
paul
noam chomsky uh i think glenn greenwell
glenn greenwald's done great work on
this jeremy scahill's done great work on
this
um uh pretty much the whole foreign
policy staff at cato
is really great um you know like cato i
don't agree with all of their stuff but
their foreign policy team is really
solid
um cool i guess that's it
for now grant green says what does dave
think about libertarians defending big
tech
they say it is a free market yet ignore
the protections they receive such as ip
protections that last 70 years
and things like section 230. yeah okay
it's just so
stupid and infuriating and i've been
battling with other libertarians about
this for a while
look here's the thing right libertarians
uh greatest
attribute is our autism
and our greatest flaw is our autism
indeed
so it's like libertarians have this
autistic thing where and this is why we
have like the best arguments for why
raising the minimum wage actually hurts
low-skilled workers because they've
really thought about this purely
but the problem is that then they get
trapped in this like world where they're
not being human beings
and they're going like well it's a
private company so a private company has
a right to discriminate it's like
yes okay but what you're not
understanding is that this libertarian
principle
will kill the future of libertarianism
if you don't
exactly look the here's the truth okay
you have to
view things and this is why i really do
like this term and think it's useful
through the lens of the cathedral the
the state is not simply
the government and government employees
it's the deep state
it's the corporate press it's academia
and and it's big business that are crony
capitalists
and it's big tech they're all working
together and doing each other's bidding
they're not separate things they're all
one thing and i think that what might
wake some libertarians up
is seeing ron paul get messages on
facebook
because do you really now remember you
ever hear that uh karl marx
line or he said the capital i don't
remember exactly but it's like the
capitalist will sell us the last piece
of rope we can use to hang him
yeah and there is some genius to that
right so it's like libertarians
do you really want to be in the position
of defending
big tech's right to silence ron paul i i
because that's pretty self-defeating i
need someone to make the meme of uh you
know they do the thing where the person
looks normal there's four panels and
they slowly change over time each panel
and it's like
my reaction watching big tech censor the
patron saint of libertarianism and then
their face slowly starts turning into a
communist flag
yeah well look at the very least and i
don't i'm not calling for any type of
government action like i know there are
people who are calling to like
nationalize
uh these industries i think that's a
crazy plan like i gotta be
you know the idea that like oh if we
nationalize it then they have to live up
to the constitution because of course
the government
always lives up to constitutional
protections like i think that's crazy
but at least criticize it don't just sit
there and be like well they have a right
to do it
being protected by the government well
yes and so take it away
not just that they're they're not
private entities they're quasi state and
yes you're right work with the
government today facebook and twitter
worked with
the state department to bring back free
speech in uganda
of all places so you look at inc you
tell you look at the government
contracts you look at the tax subsidies
these are entities that only
all
no you're absolutely right but i i do
think that in the same
sense that like where what i mean by the
autism thing is it's like
if i actually malice used this example
but it was like if a restaurant like
served you
cold rotted food and a libertarian went
well they're a private company and it's
like well why is your response to say
they're a private company the response
should be this is like
awful don't serve this this is terrible
but i do think honestly
i think your podcast on on rogan when
you basically told
jack dorsey and whoever that lawyer lady
was to their face
like how and and just destroyed them in
that debate i think
that's like the most powerful thing like
we need a lot more of that
people exposing them my respect to uh
them doing it
i genuinely believe they thought that
they were gonna
walk in and it was gonna be like here's
why we banned milo and then i would go
oh well i guess
oh they had no they were not prepared do
i remember one part it's been a little
while since i watched this but there was
one part where you like
just went on this awesome little like
rant just destroying their entire world
view
and she just gave you the most corporate
like she was just silent for a minute
and then she went
thank you for your feedback
we will discuss that with our team i
think you're like oh man that is
that is really weird there was like a
point where
i knew we had to go in to start talking
about specific individuals and then we
got to the point where i said what at
what point did you become the arbiters
of
you know what opinions are allowed in
public discourse removing people based
on your ideals and things like that
and you know i thought that was really
important part of the conversation they
didn't expect
yeah they thought it was going to be
like we ban this person because they gen
i think they
genuinely believe their world view is
the universal world view
yes so like when i explained the
misgendering thing these the leftists
don't get it
this is the thing about the left not
understanding the right and the right
understanding the left
the right knows what the left thinks
they talk about misgendering the left
doesn't understand
what the right things when they talk
about misgendering and trying to explain
it
didn't work and the and the most
important point i thought that you were
making was that
you're so biased that you don't see it
as a bias
exactly you just see it as well
obviously this is the wrong thing to do
so we're not biased we're against the
wrong thing
and you're like no it's your bias that
makes you think this is the wrong thing
well ask them specifically about body
dysmorphia
there's very similar symptoms to people
who have dysphoria and dysmorphia
and i said are you going to start
protecting people who are criticized
when they want to cut their hands off
i'm not trying to say it's the same
thing no it's just you know you it's
it's just
taking this to the logical conclusion if
we're going to do this for the reasons
you're saying then why not this
will we protect all groups that are
experiencing some kind of body
dysmorphia
or will you only limit it to your
ideological you know point of view or
towards the groups you feel should be
protected because i'll tell you this
if you want to protect the trans
community then i'll say absolutely i
think it's a noble cause and i
completely i i respect
it can we talk about the other groups
that need those same protections well
the answer was apparently no
right you know so i was like then
there's not there's no consistency in
your ideology i don't think they even
recognize that
for sure grant henley says i love dave
been a fan since 2012.
i was an exchange student in taiwan and
they hate china they are very much like
hong kong and u.s citizens
they're actually protesting for trump
yeah they're a marching form
food negotiator says david wright dave
is right although trump had the
resources to crush the establishment and
reach people as an outsider
he still lacked the real philosophical
principles to go anywhere with the
momentum
you know it is in many ways a shame that
uh
it's like to get the kind of personality
and
you know power to become president trump
had that
but he didn't have as as you know you
and they mentioned the
philosophical principles around paul
i don't think you know what i mean with
with all due respect because i like rand
paul
i don't think he has the the x factor to
be president you know no i mean i look
rand paul ran
he was in that same race it's it's the
it's the great tragedy of the whole
situation
donald trump was the only weapon that
would work he was just
he was rich enough and famous enough and
rude enough
and aggressive enough to be the one who
could beat him
but then that tool didn't actually know
how to wield power it's so funny
like we were saying downstairs before
it's like you know they call him a
dictator
not one person got put in jail for
trying to frame him for
treason they framed him for treason and
he couldn't get one person in jail over
that and they put his people in jail
yeah amazing
uh that's the angry bellsprout says
trump should have started a locals and
charged reply guys 20
a month to abuse him for those are
familiar so dave rubin has locals.com
where you can basically create your own
you know your own social network where
people go and it's just you and your
followers and your subscribers so it
really cuts out the bots and stuff
good idea i like it uh i'm doing my own
website timcast.com
which is basically similar but it's mine
but could you imagine if trump signs up
there
and then all of the people who hate
trump subscribe and pay
money because they can't let it go and
they need to hear what he has to say
that would be amazing he'd make a ton of
money there you go trump that's your
path
nathan daniel says remember we used to
say say whatever you want it's a free
country
yeah memories
funny let's see tsar kasim says tim
hey tim food for thought everyone talks
about the situation as being 1984.
consider sometime the idea and influence
of animal farm on the establishment
regressive left
i think it explains cuomo etc
interesting cuomo cuomo is now in favor
of opening things up
now that the electoral college has uh
been their votes have been counted
uh if you haven't already check out
timcast.com and you can become a member
we're going to start putting up
members only content probably really
soon we we just went up just the other
day
we're still working out some bugs so uh
bear with us but you can sign up now to
support the show
because considering the censorship
that's going on and i'll just let you
guys know
this is i don't know to what extent it's
been reported but facebook is doing a
major purge
it's not just ron paul a lot of channels
are getting hit with blanket
restrictions and bans and my page on
facebook
has received some kind of restriction i
don't know what it means or what it's
blanket
there's not it's nondescript but uh the
risk is
real so that's why we've been trying to
push really hard to get timcast.com up
and running
and start the vlog show and and do more
because we're at risk as well so
you can check that out and sign up would
greatly appreciate it
shale cara says first ever super chat if
you have dave smith on more
the more i'll be a donate dave shout out
t
w l v m and m r well i don't know what
that is
i i didn't follow that part at the end
but i i liked the general spirit of it
yeah for sure we'll definitely have
devon he's here now
tanner miner says speaking of
conspiracies in the federal reserve
how do you all fear feel about the
theory that the titanic was sunk
intentionally so that many rich men died
and the reserve was made off of that
i don't know the whole thing i only know
the titanic switch theory i haven't
heard that
i never heard that i just only you know
i only have room for so many
conspiracies in my head and
when someone brings me a new one i'm
like i just i don't have it in me
but you might be right it's fun to like
play kind of game of like mind sudoku
with these stories but i just look you
can only you can only believe so much or
you need evidence and stuff and so when
someone comes to me with some fantastic
story i'm just like i
i think it's fun but you know i'm not
gonna base my life around it
so don't look into that that's fun
sounds like a cool movie for sure yeah
so wyatt belt says tim going back to
when you were talking about
gun reform how long do you think before
hr 127 becomes law
do you guys know what hr 127 is no i'm
not familiar
no i'm not you want to look it up luke i
can look it up hr one two seven
we will check oh is that corey bush's
thing what is what is that thing house
resolution 127 about
um banning all of them punishing the
republicans
uh what does that do to provide for the
licensing of firearms and ammunition
possession
yep uh you get a license to buy ammo
yep wow how will that work will it be
like
you know it'll happen though so this is
this is what it's called to provide for
the licensing of firearm and ammunition
possession
and the registration of firearms and to
prohibit the possession of certain
ammunition whoa yeah ah so there you go
from texas
interesting oh that's gonna pass i think
it'll pass immediately
they've got control of everything it's
going to just go right through
great yeah this will be fun people are
going to get real mad
warren dent says ann coulter says rand
paul is too short to be president
[Music]
yeah she might be right about that it's
not something you can do anonymous
source says ugh i got here too late two
of my favorite podcasters dave
turn tim libertarian please what does
that mean like libertarian right
though i mean i don't i don't know i
don't really to me i don't really
consider myself
right wing but every left winger
considers me right-wing
libertarian centrist yeah i i guess
i don't i don't really know honestly i i
think of libertarian as
as its own thing like walter block he's
a great libertarian you know he says
it's the third leg on the stool there's
like the right the left and then this
is its own kind of thing it is yeah and
i that that's how i look at it
but then of course every if you're just
not a leftist
pretty much every leftist thinks you're
a right winger right like that's just
how it works i mean
it's hilarious to me i saw the thing
with that uh that vows guy or whatever
was like
well you're a far right guy and you're
like do you really like is that your
conception of the far
right is you it just seems so bizarre to
me
a mixed race pro universal healthcare
like liberal yeah liberal's easiest way
i can put it
yeah how many times have i gone have i
done podcasts where i've explained my
position on supporting
universal basic health care supplemented
by private insurance
and i'm like that's not right wing it's
probably it's like center left leaning
it's
it's a little bit more into left than
just left of center but it's not far
far left well actually it is fairly far
left actually to be honest i mean you're
like you oppose like
some of the like crazy excesses of the
woke stuff but like
culturally politically there's nothing
about you that's far
right it's just if you're not in
lockstep with them
then that's the only box you have to be
playing that was that was funny when he
called me far right i was like
dude did you read like a meme board that
called me far right
because i had a conversa i talked about
border you know protections or something
right
and it was like that was the only thing
you heard about me because bernie
sanders was in favor of it
oh yeah bernie sanders came out in i
think 2018 and he was like we got to
have border security
well there's one interview i think it's
earlier like in 2016 or something where
ezra climbed this before he got like big
into the presidential runs and he was
just being honest
and ezra klein asked him uh uh if we
should support open borders
and bernie sanders goes what no that's a
koch brothers big corporation policy
because what are you talking about you
want to like which by the way kind of
makes sense from bernie's perspective
because
it does well it also just doesn't jive
with any of his policies
like look you can argue and i think
fairly consistently
that if you have like no welfare state
none of that stuff then you can have an
ellis island situation where people come
in
but if you have if you have like health
care housing education all of these
things
paid for by the taxpayer and open
borders
they're impossible to work together this
is this goes back to what we were
talking about with occupy wall street
and the left becoming fractured all that
stuff
i supported bernie sanders in 2016. the
wokeness wasn't a big
element of his campaign he opposed the
trade agreements he was for the working
class he said open open borders as a
koch brothers proposal and i was like
this bernie guy has been consistent
he's been in government he's he knows
how the system works and he's calling it
out and i liked it
and then he got on stage and said white
people don't know what it's like to be
poor
and i was like what and there are people
who to this day still don't believe he
said it
and i show him the clip and they're
shocked by it oh he said it very
blatantly said when you're white you
don't know what it's like to be polite
and i gotta be honest for a socialist to
say this right you're like dude really
you don't understand let me introduce
you to my ukrainian friendship
like what are you talking about so that
was that was like
smack in the face but um you know it's
crazy to me that someone like vosh would
call me far right and i'm literally
like still i was praising bernie
recently the problem i have is the
weakness makes no sense
and it is hurting the working class and
causing them to fight each other how
does it make sense
that a a black woman worth a billion
dollars is more oppressed than a
homeless white man
well we're talking about supporting the
bourgeoisie and that's what you've been
throwing the proletariat out the window
and it gets to the point where like
you know when michelle obama gave her
speech
at the dnc and and she's
talking right away she's like now i know
some people disagree with me of course a
black woman up here talking to you and
blah blah you know it's like
so you your first thing has to be this
strict identitarianism
and because of racial and gender
identity you are a victim
lady your husband was elected president
twice
you're broadcasting from your mar-a-lago
home
you are talking to some truck driver
telling him that you're a victim this is
like
bananas this makes no sense and some of
these people are politicians that are
literally instituting policy like we saw
in new york city with the school
chancellor
literally arguing that if you're a poor
white person
resources should not go to you they
should go to someone of color no matter
listen joe biden just said the other day
he just gave a speech from the
president-elect little podium thing that
he does
where he said our focus is going to be
on black-owned businesses latino owned
businesses and female-owned businesses
now i am sorry that is so much more
blatantly racist than anything donald
trump's ever seen i mean can you imagine
if donald trump ever just got up there
and said
hey this one racial group they're
they're not
our focus of help but everybody else is
let me yeah they cut out asians oh yeah
they're they're on team white
so i've been thinking about it and i
think a lot of these leftists you know
people like vosh are more
pro-establishment than they are populist
because you have a choice between the
establishment pro-war machine
corporate lobbying big banks the theft
of the working class
and donald trump and for me the choice
was donald trump
even though eileen left on policies
don't agree with trump on
a fair amount of issues don't agree with
conservatives on a fair amount of issues
but agree with you know
anti-establishment principles and more
populist causes
i'd rather see someone like trump who
just like like you said he doesn't hate
these people it was like for the first
time
they experienced someone actually
fighting for him and i'm like that's
better than joe biden
he's gonna he's not left he's not uh
he's gonna gut ev
like the working class he's gonna he's
gonna strip the the wealth
and privileges that the working class
have fought so hard to try and
accomplish and give it to the
you know his wealthy elites the
corporate lobbyists the big banks so i
won't accept that
then i see these leftists being like but
we have to stop trump because he's a
fascist
i'm like what are you talking about do
it's like you know what man
you supported the the corporatist
which is so much closer to fascist yeah
these people don't have any idea and
then
and then you're gonna come and tell me
i'm right wing okay dude
congratulations you just put this this
establishment military mass murdering
regime back in power
so now when they start one day these
people are going to wake up
looking at their paychecks looking at
what's going on and they're going to be
shocked
but i'll tell you what most of them are
just tribalists anyway they don't
it's not about policy for them it's just
about which side
should or needs to win we spent a good
deal of this show
ragging on donald trump because look as
much as i often find myself in a
defensive position for him
like you were mentioning his critics are
so insane yeah you're like
donald trump could walk up to a dog and
scream at it and you start going whoa
whoa whoa but then all of a sudden you
see a news report saying donald trump
threw a puppy off a bridge and you're
like no he didn't yeah yeah that
never happened trump never did that and
like why are you defending him because
he didn't do that
yeah i can critic you know so anyway
look
i hope that the left and the right can
actually find some common ground on
populist causes
but i really do think it's mostly
tribalist i think that's the big problem
we have right now
but that being said we've uh uh our two
hour show has basically become a two and
a half hour show because we have good
conversations just kind of keep going
but if you haven't already smash the
like button because it really really
does help thanks to everybody for your
super chats
you can follow me on twitter instagram
and
mines at tim cast uh there was used to
be parlor but no you know that's gone
so uh but but you should follow me on
mines because i know bill and mines is
great as well and i put my videos up
there every day
and don't forget to go to timcast.com
become a member and this is the
important part
it's not just that there's going to be
exclusive videos and video segments
we're going to start producing very soon
but it's that we're going to be doing
actual physical events for very very
small groups
especially considering covid but the
very small groups you will get an email
notifying you
if you are a member when they go on sale
and it's going to be probably first come
first serve so become a member
and then for everybody i think just go
to the website you can
figure it out you can check it out we
are trying to work through the bugs and
get everything up and running so
please you know forgive us as we start
working through and getting things
sorted much better
improving our hosting and things like
that but uh thanks all so much for
hanging out we're live monday through
friday at 8 pm
leave us a comment hit the like button
subscribe leave us a good review on
itunes and spotify
but uh seriously thank you all so much
for hanging out and uh dave do you have
any socials or podcasts you want to
mention oh yeah well my podcast is part
of the problem
it's everywhere podcasts are uh but you
can go to gasdigitalnetwork.com that is
all my stuff there
uh my my comedy special from 2017
i put up for free on my youtube channel
uh youtube.com
d smith comic at comicdavesmith on
twitter at the problem dave smith on
instagram
i'm not on any of the cool alternative
social media sites so i might be in
trouble
but follow me there i've been i've been
bleeding followers on
on twitter so i don't know i know a lot
of people have been saying that because
twitter banned 70 000 people
yeah yeah so a lot of people isn't
followers
luke oh there we go so so look out for
my uh what was the smoke signals they're
going to be coming out very soon
uh on the youtube channel we are changed
the website is we are change.org sign up
on that email list and if you want to
support my voluntary efforts here
check out my t-shirt store and you could
buy a t-shirt like the one i'm wearing
right now that says new normal
new world order on we are change dot org
forward slash
shirts thank you guys so much i really
really appreciate you guys
very much and i'm over here pushing all
the buttons for these cool guys
my twitter at is sour patch lids l-y-d-s
thank you all so much for hanging out
we'll be back tomorrow live at 8pm you
can also check out my other youtube
channels youtube.com
timcast youtube.comcastnews i would i
have homework for everybody if you're so
inclined
have a have a chill session just chill
out put your phone down put it on mute
get away from the internet
watch some cartoons hang out with your
friends and your family just chill and
relax
and then come back tomorrow because
we're gonna be talking news again at 8pm
and we will see you all then
bye guys
you